welcome back to another episode of the
stronger by science podcast in today's
episode we discuss a wide range of
topics including resting metabolic rate
standing desks artificial sweeteners
electromyography sleep plant-based
proteins and much more then to close out
the episode Gregg is back with even more
cooking tips as always thank you for
listening and enjoy the show welcome
back to another episode of the stronger
by science podcast this is your host
Eric Trexler and today I'm joined by a
very special guest host named Greg
Nickels thanks for having me oh thank
you for joining me this is a big day for
us for all of our listeners it's the day
before Valentine's Day did I celebrate
that internationally that's probably
just an American thing right I really
don't know we should have checked on
that if you're if you're an
international listener residing outside
of the United States maybe start the
trend you know
February 14th every year now it's
Valentine's Day wherever you happen to
be but but it is an important day and
we're really glad I'm sure most people
listening right now have the lights
dimmed down a little bit bottle of wine
chilling you and your significant other
and we're really happy that we could
accompany you as the kind of musical
backdrop for that yeah we recognize that
probably 80% of our listeners are going
to be listening to this episode of the
podcast either immediately before or
during coitus that being the case we're
going to attempt to avoid any subjects
that could you know potentially ruin the
mood and mess with your Valentine's Day
celebrations yeah every topic is going
to be either neutral to sexy
but we're not gonna go the other
direction correct yeah
so on anyway like I said it's just a
huge honor to be part of that process
with all of our listeners so yeah and
we're really excited about what we have
keyed up I'm gonna start with feats of
strength like normal have a little Q&A
segment have a research roundup and then
a really really cool segment on how to
know if your bowel movements are are
proper and healthy or not so all very
valentine's day appropriate topics I
wish you wouldn't say that cuz that
that's not true but it's a very that's a
very realistic thing that we might do so
I don't want you to get people's hopes
up that segment is not coming I mean it
was a joke because you just said or we
just said not gonna do anything that
would ruin the mood oh I get it
I mean that could heighten the mood for
some people we don't keep stronger by
science podcast let's just move forward
I believe you've got some feats of
strength I do so starting with the big
one which I assume everyone's seen by
this point Jamaal browner who we've
talked about on the podcast before
exceptional dead lifter had put up big
numbers but not world record numbers and
meats before largely because he had grip
issues but had pulled just outrageous
weights with straps in the gym he has
apparently gotten his grip issues either
all or mostly sorted out
I think he's pulled something over a
thousand in the gym before which is wild
at 242 but he put up a number very very
close to that on the platform recently
he pulled for 40 and a half kilos which
is nine hundred and seventy-one pounds
in the 110 kilo class or the 242 pound
class that actually chips
Yuriy belkin's world record which was
previously for forty kilos and if you
look at the video of this it looked easy
it looked like there was plenty more in
the tank
I don't think browner is much of a
grinder but it could very well be that
he still has like some grip issues and
you know maybe he's good for over a
thousand but like nine seven he's just
kind of the limit of his hook grip at
the moment but regardless takes that
world record did it in style so congrats
to him for for finally like putting the
type of number on a platform that he has
looked to be capable of for a long time
now a little bit less covered was he
also took the without wraps world record
total in the weight class in the same
meet he totaled 990 kilos or 2182 so
very very good performance all around
and congrats to him moving on someone
else we talked about on the podcast
before was Kevin oak so I think last
maybe like last september/october there
abouts he broke omits appears world
record for the no wraps squat in the two
forty two or a hundred and ten kilo
class he squatted three hundred and
eighty kilos then he added ten kilos to
his own world record squatted three
ninety or eight hundred and fifty nine
pounds which is also just wild that's
what's such a big number congrats to him
moving on to probably the other recent
feat of strength that most people are
probably aware of by this point and
moving out of powerlifting Hathor
bjornsen thor the mountain from game of
thrones if you don't follow strongman he
pulled 455 kilos or a thousand and three
pounds for a smooth double in the gym a
slight point of contention there is he
used what's it called
i think it's called the elephant bar
it's like a rogue specialty bar which is
a little bit Whittier than a standard
barbell i think he claims that it's not
really giving him anything other people
are saying like ah no he's not gonna
pull this on a standard competition bar
i think he's planning on taking a crack
at eddie halls 500 kilo deadlift records
soon so you know we'll see how that
shakes down but it's now looking like
two people have very very legitimate
shots at pulling 500 kilos we talked
about yvonne Makarov last year Russian
strongman came very very close to
pulling 501 Thor pulling 455 for a
double seems to be pretty close to that
area now as well so yeah who knows we
may we may see another 1 or 2 500 kilo
dead lifters in the next calendar year
don't know if it's gonna happen or not
but I would love to see it yeah I
actually saw this one the stronger by
our dietitian at stronger by science
Greg Schulz he made me
watch the video here honestly it looked
like you get it it looked like he had
five in him all right like I said it -
it was pretty wild dude yeah he the the
first one looked like it was never in
doubt but it looked like he was putting
effort into it and then the second one
was smooth as butter yeah like he at
least had a third Oh
easy yeah so yeah I mean there have been
how what maybe like six people pull over
a thousand in some way shape or form
before I think he and Eddie hall and
maybe Makarov are the only ones I've
ever seen pull multiple reps at over a
thousand so yeah I mean that's it's wild
moving on
Casey Romero which I feel like I may not
follow powerlifting quite closely enough
cuz I hadn't heard of her
looked her up on open powerlifting she's
never been like a world record level
lifter but she's been quite good for a
few years now but this was the first I
heard of her
posted a training lift on Instagram of
pulling six hundred and twenty-five
pounds or two hundred and eighty-three
kilos that is the heaviest raw deadlift
by a female lifter ever on video as far
as I'm aware if you add equipped lifters
into the mix Becca Swanson who is a
legendary power lifter that I feel like
not enough people know about anymore
because she competed in gear and now
people don't pay attention to multiply
that much anymore
she pulled 695 I'm pretty sure that's
super heavy in multiply which is wild
and most people I've talked to who who
Det like who compete in multiply say
they don't really get that much for the
deadlift like it's it's a big hell for
the squat and bench but not quite as
much for the deadlift so Becca got 695
back in the day but Casey Romero pulling
625 is is crazy I'm pretty sure the
highest ever in competition is 6:15
and of note kc romero to her last meet
she competed at super heavyweight but i
kind of think the super heavyweight
class for female lifters is dumb because
she weighed in at ninety four point four
kilos which is two hundred and eight
pounds and like I don't know I kind of
feel like that shouldn't be lumped into
the super heavyweight class for the IPF
the top weight capped class is eighty
four for non IPF feds it's 90 kilos and
I think that that's I think that's kind
of a [ __ ] top weight capped class
because if you look at like the
difference between kind of the average
body weight of males and the top weight
capped class which is 120 in IPF and its
affiliates and 140 and other feds that's
that's a lot further from the average
weight of a typical male than 84 90
kilos is away from the average weight of
a typical female so I kind of feel like
there should maybe be like a 100 or a
105 kilo class for females before the
supers
but regardless I mean even competing as
a super that's the biggest raw deadlift
any female has put up on video that I'm
aware of
I think the next highest is 615 of note
she used straps she admitted in her
Instagram caption that she gets quite a
bit out of them
I think her heaviest deadlift in a meet
so far is 540 or 245 kilos but I mean
even with straps like I mean anyone
pulling anyone pulling 600 plus in the
neighborhood of 200 pounds
he's [ __ ] strong and a female doing
that even more impressive and for that
to be the heaviest raw female deadlift
of all time even more impressive go
check that out super super cool moving
on to something that's less surprising
seems to be essentially in inevitability
at this point
Daiki Kodama competed recently japanese
bench press specialist he broke his own
world record in the 74 kilo class he
benched 226 at 74 which is 4
ninety-eight at a body weight of like
163 164 he previously held the record at
225 kilos or what is that 795 796 I did
not watch the footage of this meet I saw
that he got red lighted on his third
attempt at 2:30 because his hands were
set too wide I don't know whether he
took that attempt to got it and then got
red lights for his grip being too wide
or whether they just didn't let him take
the attempt yeah he continues to break
his own world record seems like he does
pretty much every time he competes just
outrageously strong at that bodyweight
and then last thing another bench feat
so Johnny Harris who has benched I
believe 658 in a meat or 297 and a half
kilos he recently posted a gym lift of a
700 pound bench hasn't done it in a meet
yet it's hard to tell from the angle
looks like his butt maybe came up I
don't give a [ __ ] it's 700 pounds
touched his chest locked it out like as
far as I'm concerned got 700 pounds on
the bar and you do it it's [ __ ] cool
no matter how it looks
so the noteworthy thing about that is
even counting gym lifts he's now only I
believe the sixth person ever to bench
over 700 and is is pretty comfortably
the lightest so I don't know what his
body weight is now he competed in
November and as of November his body
weight was 287 point 7 pounds which is a
hundred and thirty and a half kilos the
next lightest person to ever bench 700
was Scott Mendelssohn at a body weight
of a hundred and forty kilos or 308
pounds so he's he's like 10 kilos
lighter than the next person to ever put
up that number I mean when I got into
the sport I'm pretty sure Scott
Mendelssohn and James Henderson were the
only people who'd ever benched
700
period and Scott was wild in that he did
it in the 308 class and people are
talking like is is well one is anyone
ever going to pinch 700 again
they clearly have but then - is anyone
ever going to be able to do that at a
body weight below 300 Johnny Harris at
least at this point has done it in the
gym we'll see if he can put it on the
platform but congrats to him very very
big bench very cool stuff all right very
nice
so moving on we've got a nice round of
Q&A questions coming up here and the
first one is directed at me this one's
actually from Greg Schulz oh sweet his
second honorable mention of the day I
think that gets you an honorary Rd I
believe so yeah so you want to go ahead
and read me in here yeah so Greg Schulz
asks Eric hey Eric can you cover the
parentheses in close parentheses
accuracies of online RM are calculators
on the podcast yeah and so I was talking
to the other Greg Greg Schulz about this
and it's something he gets a lot of
questions about from clients and people
on the Internet
people seem to be really interested in
trying to get an estimate of what their
resting metabolic rate is and so I will
address you know exactly how accurate or
inaccurate some of those equations are
but my practical take-home point is well
I'll get to it when we cross that bridge
so there's two studies I want to focus
on here the first one the the author's
last name is spelled J a GIM I should
know how to say Andrews last name I'm
90% sure it's Jagan I didn't know you
know how sometimes people will be like
younger or something I didn't know if it
was like that soft J so I I was on the
podcast that he had it was him and Andy
asked Al and I asked him how to
pronounce his name so I feel even worse
for not being positive yeah I'm 99% sure
I asked him and it was just Jagan know
he does cool stuff and the man I'm
almost certain I've met him at a
conference and I know I've interacted
with him online so it's just
embarrassing that I don't know
but we just mispronounced everything and
we're moving forward so he did a nice
study looking at several these equations
and basically just you know measuring
resting metabolic rate and seeing
essentially how close to these equations
get and they looked at males and females
separately in their analysis and there's
a few different ways you can look it at
trying to assess what kind of error
these equations are giving you and so
you might be tempted to look at just the
simplest thing right so we got a sample
of people and we could just look at what
were the averages what was the average
resting metabolic rate measured and what
was the average rate predicted and how
different are those averages but it's
really not a great way of looking at it
and so a painfully basic example is Greg
let's say you and I get our get our
metabolic rate tested and let's say the
the equation overestimates mine by 300
and it underestimates yours by 300 well
it basically would say oh cool this
equation works pretty well on average it
gets you right there right right sorry
what what we look at with these types of
studies my favorite metric is called the
root mean square error and so it's
exactly what it sounds like we're
looking at the error or the difference
between the measured and the predicted
value and what we do is we square those
values we take the mean of those squares
and then we take the square root and
what that does is it can account for for
just the fact that it was a bad
predictor whether or not it over or
underestimated it can give us a better
idea of generally speaking how off is
this thing how much does that differ
from just the absolute value of the
average error or like like the the
average of the absolute values of the
errors like I I know squaring it makes
everything positive and then square
rooting again so it it essentially
accomplished accomplishes something
similar but like just in terms of does
that inflate or deflate the error just
relative to absolute values I don't know
I'd have to look into it I don't know
off the top of my head I'm not sure it
should be similar yeah
sure it's getting at the same thing
regardless right yeah so so the idea is
we want to get an idea of on average
approximately how off are these
estimates and so when you look at the
the root mean square error values for
the male's in this study they're
generally in the 300 to 400 range so
they looked at like what is that 5
different equations there the lowest
error was 284 calories the highest was
466 so I mean when we're talking about a
difference of 300 calories plus or minus
that's a pretty sizable difference when
they looked at their the females in
their sample the the lowest root mean
square error was 110 calories per day
for a metabolic rate and the highest was
228 so it would look at surface value
like there's a big difference between
men and women but when you express that
as a percent of metabolic rate it was
basically off for the male's by you know
12 to 19 percent
so basically scaling it to their their
overall metabolic rate in the females it
was a little bit lower but not not by a
ton it was like seven to fifteen percent
now there was another study by Grant
Tinsley and if you listen to the show
you know I'm a big fan of grant he's a
good friend he does really cool really
cool research I feel like I always bring
up his studies because he always studies
the stuff that I would want to study you
know so anyway so he did a similar study
this is his analysis the table I'm
looking at here is just combining the
males and females like I'm almost
certain he did separate it out but I
just went for the combine table and this
was from 27 total participants but
looking through it on average again he
looked at the root mean square error in
this paper it was called total error but
if you look in the methods that it was
an equivalent metric and basically it
was right around the same area it was in
the you know 200 to 300 range which
given the fact that it's a combined
sample of males and females puts it on
pretty similar terms with with the
previous study so overall it looks like
these equations generally speaking tend
to get you within a few hundred calories
but I wouldn't
look at them as being much more precise
than that
and so what was interesting was I saw in
the in grant study he even compared
three different machines for measuring
metabolic rate and the root mean square
errors for those compared to they used
the the parvo medics cart as like the
you know the standard to which they
compared which makes sense but he used
two other different pieces of equipment
and they differed by a hundred and
seventy-five calories and the other one
was like five hundred and fifty seven
calories different whole [ __ ] which is
that's a lot and so yeah I mean I think
that did worse than any of the
prediction equations so like even the
worst predictive equation had a lower
root mean square error than that device
yeah then one of the lesser metabolic
carts yeah and so that's something to
keep in mind like if you're just going
and like somebody at the gym like grabs
this thing in the back of the personal
training office and says hey blow into
this it's gonna tell us your metabolic
rate holy [ __ ] that other metabolic cart
was trash yeah we also just looked at
correlations to see like how well the
prediction equations and like the other
metabolic carts like whether they were
significantly associated with with what
you were getting from the parvo and all
of the other ones work which is what
you'd expect you would expect you know
very strong associations there so like
our values all point eight nine or above
p-values less than zero point oh oh oh
set three or four O's whatever that's
three oh yeah less than 0.0001 and then
for what is that breezing I've never
heard of that cart maybe there's a
reason for that Greg yeah well the the
correlation coefficient is 0.28 and it's
not a significant Association it's like
unless it's just [ __ ] trash you
should expect a significant association
oh yeah so that there are that's
outrageous the r-squared value is point
so if your measurement on that device Oh
accounts for 8% of the variance and the
actual comparative measure that's that's
alarmingly bad that yeah that's not good
so the moral of the story here is you
know using all these various equations
certainly they differ to some extent but
you're really only using them to get you
within a few hundred calories and for
most people I think they're hoping and
essentially counting on a greater a
greater magnitude of precision than that
I think a lot of people have excessive
confidence in the number they get from
some of these equations now I don't want
to bad-mouth the concept of using these
equations they should get you into a
pretty close range and that's great and
that's what they're used for but at that
point you got to let you got to let your
observations take over so you know if
you're coaching somebody through a
weight loss program and they're like
where should I start in many cases this
is your best starting point of trying to
get some idea of resting metabolic rate
then you use a multiplier to try to get
an estimate of their energy expenditure
you know their non resting energy
expenditure and that's just your
starting point and then you go from
there but but you know if you're
listening don't get don't get too caught
up on the e don't overestimate the
precision from these equations because
they're probably just gonna get you in
the ballpark again these these root mean
square error values are generally in the
300 ish range give or take but I think
the more important take-home point that
I kind of alluded to before I started
here I just don't think resting
metabolic rate is particularly
interesting and the reason I say that is
because it's not particularly malleable
so we could get an idea of what it is
and there's really not much we can do
with it you know that there's really
nothing you can do to shape it and to
change it in the way you want I mean
certainly it'll go down if you starve
yourself but that's not really useful
information for anybody so I try not to
get too bogged down and
what sometimes I'll have people who say
like I think I've metabolic adaptation
I'm gonna go get my resting metabolic
rate checked and that's okay but first
of all if we get that information
there's really not much we can do with
it and more importantly if we're talking
about metabolic adaptation we're much
more interested in non resting
components of energy expenditure so the
studies looking at people that are
metabolically adapted in an unfavorable
way within the context of weight loss we
find that their resting metabolic rate
isn't that different than normal if
they're eating at energy balance when
they're measured but the real the brunt
of that adaptation is happening to non
resting aspects of metabolic rates so
the problem is if you think you are like
quite metabolically adapted and you want
to troubleshoot it even getting that
number is not a particularly helpful
thing to get so so I answered the
question directly but then the the
caveat is I don't think it's that
important and really you shouldn't be
using these these predictive equations
for anything other than getting a
starting point if you have literally no
idea how much energy a person's spending
in a given day okay moving on so there
was a bar bhalo study actually I think
here's I'm gonna flex a little bit I
think that's actually probably
pronounced bar Baldy oh sure I I did two
weeks of learning Portuguese using that
little app with a little owl duolingo
yeah yeah I think I think that H is
pronounced as a Y and if that's true
that should forgive me for all of my
mispronunciations up to this point on
the show but anyway so they had a study
that came out looking at the back squat
versus the hip thrust there have been a
lot of people commenting on it and you
had a bit of a methodological tidbit to
share on that I believe uh it kind of
yeah so not gonna not gonna pin this
question on anyone in particular because
on our Q&A forum there were like seven
people who asked about this study so
just generally responding to all of them
so a study was recently published
old back squat versus hip thrust back
squat versus hip thrust resistance
training programs in well-trained women
by I'm saying bar below I mean dude you
can do that at your own peril sure
anyway so this is a study that has
caused a reasonable amount of is
controversy the right word maybe
controversies the right word there's
been a lot of ink spilled about it with
in the fitness industry in the in the
past couple of weeks and if I only cared
about growing this media empire and
getting clicks to the podcast at all
costs and was essentially more of a
sellout I would also have hot takes to
share about this study right now I feel
pretty confident saying I am going to
talk about it more at some point but
this is not the appropriate time however
I do think that there's hopefully is
somewhat interesting and maybe useful
point that I can kind of pull out of all
of this and it's essentially why were
people surprised by the results of the
study in the first place
so the key result of the study that most
people have been talking about is that
according to the data presented in the
study squats caused more glute growth
than hip thrusted in pretty well-trained
women actually quite well-trained women
for a research sample pre training they
were squatting about 200 pounds asked to
grass they specified to a knee angle of
140 degrees which is pretty [ __ ] deep
so that's you know those are pretty well
trained women and they had them trained
for I believe ten weeks one group only
doing squats the only group the other
group only doing hip thrusts and the
group that squatted according to the
results of the study had more glute
growth or a larger increase include
thickness as assessed by ultrasound and
so that was like I said pretty
surprising to a lot of people one of the
reasons why is because there had been
previous am
research showing that peak and mean EMG
of the gluteus maximus was higher in the
hip thrust than in the back squat and so
people took that to then infer that that
hip thrust would cause more glute growth
than back squats would so I kind of want
to back up and just generally talk about
when I personally think EMG is useful
versus not in like a practical sense so
there's a lot of times where where it's
useful just if you're interested in
mechanistic research but in terms of you
know you're a lifter you're a coach you
come across a study that uses EMG how
much stock should you put in it when
reading the results of that study so
yeah just kind of want to talk about
that for a little bit
so essentially EMG stands for
electromyography and what you do is you
use electrodes to measure the electrical
activity within a target muscle and so
electrical activity is not it's not
one-to-one the same thing as muscle
activation or motor unit recruitment but
it is strongly associated with muscle
activation motor unit recruitment muscle
activation is then related to tension
and tension is one of the key drivers
and certainly the key initiator of
muscle growth so people will often use
EMG research to justify exercise
selection and act as if it's like an A
to B type thing of we're measuring
muscle activation and therefore tension
and therefore the thing with higher EMG
readings is going to cause more muscle
growth as if it's just an A to B thing
but really it's more like EMG is a and
then motor unit recruitment would be B
and then tension would be C and then
actual growth would be D when filtered
through like range of motion and
biomechanics and other things so it's
kind of like making an A to E jump which
which is always going to be a little bit
dangerous for any sort of proxy measure
but I think it's it's more or less
justifiable to do that in some
situations rather than others so when I
think you you can use EMG at least as
like weak evidence for you know coming
up with ideas about exercise selection
is when you don't have longitudinal
research actually assessing different
exercises or different techniques on
muscle growth but you do have EMG
research for two biomechanically similar
movements so by that what I mean is to
this point unless I'm mistaken there's
still not any research comparing say
tricep growth in a wide grip versus a
close grip bench press however those are
two biomechanically similar movements
and it's not really worth digging into
all of those studies because it's it's
actually fairly equivocal if you look at
the research that's out there looking at
triceps EMG and Close Grip vs. wide grip
bench press but let's just assume that
haha that those studies do show greater
triceps EMG in the close grip bench
press that combined with the fact that
you're dealing with a longer elbow range
of motion you could say like hey you
know we don't have longitudinal research
on this but we have some EMG data
showing and maybe close grip bench is a
little bit better we see that there's
also a longer joint range of motion
which is generally good and you know
practical experience tends to indicate
that you know people who are big and
strong who are trying to press for
triceps growth often recommend close
grip bench press so it kind of has some
like quote unquote in the trenches
support all of that put together you
know would seem to indicate maybe Close
Grip is a better option here so it's not
relying solely on EMG and you're dealing
with two very biomechanically similar
movements in this particular case when
you're talking about a squat versus a
hip thrust I don't necessarily think you
can use EMG to make that comparison
or at least make it well because they're
just two very biomechanically dissimilar
movements so different muscles have
different EMG angle curves so if you've
learned biomechanics you may have heard
about various muscles like length
tension curves or different joints like
torque angle curves there's also an EMG
angle curve so essentially like you can
get higher EMG readings at certain
muscles at certain lengths versus others
and like the muscle length where you get
peak EMG isn't you you can't necessarily
assume that that's also the place where
you get peak motor unit recruitment or
certainly like a peak tension and so for
example in the squat you get peak glute
EMG kind of like in the mid-range of the
exercise so glute EMG is actually very
very low at the very bottom of a squat
kind of Rises Peaks somewhere around the
sticking point and then it's quite low
by lock out with the hip thrusts on the
other hand it's kind of low ish at the
start of a hip thrust and then is very
very high like as your hips lock out and
a hip thrust and I don't know the EMG
angle curve or the EMG length
relationship of the glutes right off the
top of my head
Brett Contreras would probably be a
better person to ask about that but I'm
pretty sure you do get peak glute EMG in
like a fully extended hip position so
all else being equal if squats and hip
thrusts were say getting so if you were
stressing the glutes as hard as you
possibly could in the sticking point of
a squat and as hard as you possibly
could at the lockout of a hip extension
muscular tension very well may be
comparable but EMG would still be higher
at the lockout of a hip thrust just
because like the electrical activity you
see in a muscle differs based on what
joint angle you're dealing with and so
you know not to pick on the squat and
hip thrust too much but that's that's a
fairly generalizable principle if you're
comparing two very very different
exercises
you could just be dealing with kind of
like a peak EMG for that exercise at a
point in the like muscle length EMG
relationship associated with higher or
lower EMG and so like for example if you
were trying to say like hey I want to
pick out an exercise for I don't know
delt growth and I'm gonna compare like
I'm gonna look at a study with like
lateral raises versus shoulder press I
don't know if a study like that exists
but if it did I wouldn't pay much mind
to it just because like the the
biomechanics of those two exercises are
considerably different and so so that's
sort of critique would apply to both
just very very biomechanically
dissimilar exercises or exercises with
very very different ranges of motion so
i believe that there was a study on
squats published a while back should
have pulled this up but it was basically
comparing load equated full or like
relative load equated full squats versus
half squats so you know heavier weights
for the half squats than the full squats
but similar in relation to those two
different movements one RMS and found
like fairly similar quad EMG for those
two exercises however there have been
several studies now comparing quad
growth after partial versus full squats
finding more quad growth with full
squats and partial squats so even though
the EMG is similar there's like there's
another factor to consider that being
range of motion and like the stretch put
on the muscle at the bottom of a squat
so even though you see similar EMG you
can't necessarily infer similar
hypertrophic potential so anyway the big
point I'm trying to make is you know if
in the absence of longitudinal research
if if you don't have if you don't have
longitudinal studies you do have EMG and
you're dealing with two biomechanically
similar exercises you know maybe pay a
little attention to the EMG stuff if
you're dealing with two very
biomechanically dissimilar exercises I'm
not personally going to worry about it
too much
the only other time where I think it's
sometimes useful and this is like a
pretty a pretty niche circumstance is if
someone is making an argument that
doesn't really make any biomechanical
sense and you can find EMG research to
show like hey look you know we're seeing
virtually no EMG here like there's a
very little activation going on this
argument you're trying to make is
relatively nonsensical and so for
example I wrote an article a while back
called lats and the benchpress much ado
about very little a lot of people claim
that the lats are one of the prime
movers and the bench press and that like
having weak lats could severely limit
your bench press strength and so like
there have been a few EMG studies that
have looked at lat EMG and the bench
press and it's not much going on I think
very very low lat activation in the
bench press which would lead one to
think like hmm it's probably not really
a prime mover here and also if you're
getting you know a very very small
percentage of the juice out of the lats
that you could be getting weak lats
probably aren't going to be a major
limiter of benchpress performance I mean
theoretically it's possible that if you
just have absurdly strong pecs and just
garbage garbage weak lats like maybe in
some theoretical scenario it could be a
limiter but probably not often and so
like incredibly low EMG readings could
be a small part of a case like that but
yeah for the most part if you're if you
have longitudinal research showing
they're like hey this exercise seems to
cause more growth than that exercise
your default should be to you know rely
on longitudinal research versus EMG
stuff if you don't have that in your
dealing with biomechanically similar
exercises I think you can take EMG
differences as weak evidence in favor of
one exercise or variation over the other
if you're dealing with two very
different exercises
just don't worry about EMG I don't think
I don't think you should use that as
kind of evidence for one exercise over
the other I want to see that physique
with the extremely strong pecs and lats
so weak that they're the primary
limiting factor that would be
fascinating yeah I mean I guess it's
theoretically possible but I've never
seen it yeah all right moving on then
yeah so we have a question from Duke
Duke asks Eric I've heard that having
additional muscle mass can have effects
on metabolism is this true if so can you
please explain why Thanks yes so that's
a good question it comes up quite a lot
now I think one of the things that
contributes to this is it would be very
fair and very true to say that fat free
mass is a big-time predictor of resting
metabolic rate to the extent that some
predictive equations which we've talked
about previously some of them only
really factor in I think it's the
Cunningham equation only factors in
basically your fat free mass and so
people think okay fat free mass if
you're someone like us you basically
default that too we're talking about
muscle you know what I mean so I think a
lot of people are making and obviously
that's not an accurate leap to make but
a lot of us when we think fat free mass
we're thinking okay let's talk
hypertrophy now lean tissue certainly do
have high metabolic rates relative to
fat tissue and there's a nice table in
one of the the ISSN position statements
that goes through different tissues and
and puts down their their metabolic rate
at rest for a kilogram of tissue now
obviously we have a lot more of some of
these tissues than we do of others so
this is scaled per kilogram per day so
for example adipose tissue fat tissue
we're talking about four and a half
calories per kilogram per day so that's
pretty low other kind of miscellaneous
tissues bones skin intestines glands is
12 calories muscle is 13 but the real
heavy hitters when we get to like the
liver that's 200
the brain is 240 the heart is 400 and
the kidneys are 400 so I think a lot of
times we think of muscle tissue as this
like insanely overly metabolically
active tissue and it's certainly far
more active than than adipose tissue but
when you compare it to like the brain
and the heart per kilogram not even
close okay well and in terms of total
expenditure your your brain and all of
your muscle mass are fairly comparable
correct yeah and so I think a lot of
times you know people think okay well if
I gain muscle my fat free mass is gonna
go up and then my metabolic rate is
gonna go up as an extension of that and
that is true to some extent but like I
said per kilogram we're only talking
about 13 calories per day in terms of
energy expenditure so I mean 10
kilograms is a very meaningful amount of
muscle mass to put on extremely
meaningful you you put on 10 kilograms
of muscle mass every person you meet
that hasn't seen you in a while says oh
my god what happened right oh oh my god
what's recycle exactly yeah and so uh if
you do if you're one of those fortunate
people you put on those 10 kilograms of
solid muscle your resting metabolic rate
is you know just a quick calculation is
likely to go up by about 130 calories
per day so even with really really
impressive gains in muscle mass the
overall effect on on resting metabolic
rate is not particularly huge I wouldn't
call it negligible but it's it's not
particularly huge now I will say a lot
of people have this conversation they
leave it at that and in terms of
practical application I think that's a
fine place to end it you know it's
basically hey it's not gonna go up that
much so don't don't put all your eggs in
that basket of I'm gonna gain muscle so
I can eat everything in sight however
it's not necessarily that simple so as I
mentioned we're talking just about the
the metabolic rate of these different
tissues at rest now if you do put on a
ton of muscle obviously you have more
to activate during training and when you
are doing any kind of ambulatory
movement running walking you know
anything where you're bearing your
weight then you are moving a larger body
and sacrificing some economy
theoretically
so that might also give you a little a
little boost upward in terms of your
total energy expenditure but those are
just me being very nitpicky and kind of
mining through details for all intents
and purposes gaining muscle within a
realistic range of muscle gain is
probably not your key to drastically
increasing your total daily energy
expenditure you're much better off just
looking at I would say better off
looking at where can I get some
non-exercise activity kind of injected
into my day it has probably your best
option okay moving on we've got a
question from Dustin this question is
when combining unilateral and bilateral
training in the same training session is
it more advantageous in terms of
strength and hypertrophy to do
unilateral or bilateral exercises first
yeah so I think the answer to this is
basically the answer to any question
about what order exercises exercises
should come in a training session and
that's that it mostly just depends on
your priorities so exercises that are
more important to you or matter more to
you in terms of the results you're going
to get from them put them earlier in a
training session so there's there's
probably some exceptions to that so for
example if you care more about say your
1 rep max back squat then your 1 rep max
snatch but you're going to snatch and
back squat in the same training session
may still be a better idea to snatch
before you squat because you know doing
squats after snatches is fine doing
snatches after squats your snatch your
snatch training is gonna suck but for
the most part you know whatever exercise
matters to you more do it first so if
your main goal is strength then the
exercises you most want to improve
strengthen should come earlier in your
workout so in your example you know if
you mostly care about strength in the
unilateral leg extension you know do
that before you do bilateral training if
you care more about the strength
outcomes of the bilateral exercises do
that before the unilateral leg extension
for hypertrophy I think it it kind of
comes down to to a question of of like
maximizing outcomes versus I guess like
efficiency in a way so here's what I
mean by that if you say really really
want to maximize let's say hamstrings
hypertrophy and you are going to do both
leg curls and deadlifts in a single
session but you do also want to grow
your back and your glutes and everything
else it may not be a great idea to do
the hamstring curls first because maybe
that's going to limit deadlift
performance so much that you now need to
add in additional exercises for your
lumbar extensors and your glutes to get
them an adequate training stimulus for
growth whereas like if your hamstrings
weren't pre fatigued maybe you want to
need to but for the most part I think a
decent default is starting with
bilateral multi-joint movements and then
moving on to unilateral and then finally
single joint movements but if there is a
particular unilateral movement that
matters way way more to you for whatever
reason so you know maybe you just really
really want to have the biggest single
leg squat of anyone in your friend group
you know do single leg squats first it's
gonna be fine and as far as hypertrophy
outcomes go as long as you are
ultimately doing enough hard sets and
adequately fatiguing the target muscles
you'll probably be fine but for the most
part in most circumstances I probably
recommend starting with with the
bilateral stuff
but that's just me there are some
exceptions I would say to the general
principle of doing exercises earlier and
a workout that matter more to you but I
think most of those exceptions like I
said are either going to be something
where you're dealing with a fatigue like
a more versus dramatically less
fatiguing exercise so say squats versus
snatches or if you're doing things as
kind of more part of a warm-up and for
an actual training stimulus so a tip
that I saw from John Meadows back in the
day was to do not like super super hard
but like just do some leg curls before
you squat he said that that anecdotally
just made his knees feel a lot better
and just helped squats feel nicer I gave
it a shot I actually really liked it I
did that too back in the day oh hell
yeah yeah and I got it from him I loved
it sweet thank you John
so I have no no good explanation for why
that works but uh and I don't train at a
gym with a with a leg curl anymore but
what I did I would typically do like
curls before squats and they were great
but that was more of like a warm-up
thing so you know if I kind of fatigue
the knee flexion function of the of the
hamstrings before squatting that's not
gonna necessarily limit my squat
performance and I just felt it was more
of a warm-up thing than anything else
or if you're say doing like a
quote-unquote activation exercise before
before a core lift I think that could be
beneficial so a lot of people report
that they feel like they can get their
glutes into the deadlift better at
lockout if they do some like not super
hard but like some light hip thrusts
before they deadlift
so you know I guess a deadlift isn't
strictly a single joint exercise but it
kind of is but yeah like in that case
like even if the deadlift is what
matters more to you doing that other
exercise for activation purposes before
you deadlift may be beneficial but yeah
for the most part I think just the
general principle of exercises that
matter more do you put them earlier in
your workout will get you
you know 80% of the way there for
properly ordering exercises within a
training session sounds good let's get
back to nutrition let's do the good
stuff alright Bobby B Robert Baratheon
himself I am assuming asks Eric I
recently reviewed the vital parentheses
of vitamin D and Omega 3 findings that
were sponsored by Brigham and Women's
Brigham and Women's Hospital it's just
some Hospital and I think it's Brigham
Brigham's Women's Hospital no ok
actually I think my brother's fiancee
works there if I'm not mistaken I should
know that but it's some Hospital okay so
reviewed a trial about vitamin D and
Omega 3 sponsored by a Women's Hospital
in Boston and I was disappointed to find
that the two supplements that I thought
were actually worth taking had such poor
results well I never expected a cure for
cancer from either vitamin D or fish oil
I was particularly disappointed to see
that there weren't any differences in
cardiovascular health outcomes either
Gregg Eric Eric
do either of you guys still see a point
in vitamin D and fish oil
supplementation I'd like to hear your
thoughts on vital yes so this is kind of
the inverse of what usually happens
usually people see one really promising
trial and they're like hell yeah and
they're like really stoked about it and
we always say hey relax don't get too
excited about one trial
you know let's look at the the total
body of literature in aggregate and so
this is the inverse of that right of you
know a study comes out they're high
hopes it falls a little flat in terms of
outcomes and you go ah crap but again
you know let's take a take a broader
look at the overall body of literature
so we'll start with the vital study it
last I checked it was still ongoing huge
huge study very well funded almost
26,000 men and women across the u.s.
participating in one one way shape or
form
holy [ __ ] that's awesome it's a large
study and so they're looking at vitamin
d3 2000 I use they're also looking at
omega-3 fatty acids a gram of fish oil
being the dose
and you know they're looking at
different cancer and cardiovascular
outcomes the key findings the paper I
found most recently reporting findings
from the trial for vitamin D
supplementation they did not find a
reduced risk of cancer they did not find
a reduced risk of major cardiovascular
events they found some evidence that it
might have had some small reduction in
cancer related death so not reduced
rates of cancer but cancer related death
okay with the omega-3 fatty acid results
they found no reduction in cancer risk
they did not find any reduction in the
risk of major cardiovascular events
overall but they did find a small effect
in the people that specifically had low
fish intake within the cohort
they found that the risk of heart attack
was reduced by 28% when heart attack was
considered separately from other
cardiovascular events so I think their
initial analysis just kind of grouped
all the cardiovascular events together
but when they kind of parsed it out a
little bit they did find some some
semblance of an effect for heart attack
risk so that's one study but there was a
very recent meta-analysis whenever
possible I like to lean on a really
well-done meta-analysis to get a better
more comprehensive look at the
literature so what was cool about this
one is sometimes you'll see people who
they'll do a meta and they'll like well
you'll see people saying oh they
excluded this study that would have
really jacked up their results right I
think with this particular meta not only
did they include that Vidal trial but
the the one of the authors the senior
author of the meta was one of the
authors on the vital trial like so acai
I think it kind of depends on I think it
kind of depends on the size of the
trials in the meta so there was there's
a paper published I believe in JAMA
maybe like 2012 2013 basically looking
to see so you know we assume that like a
large well controlled RCT
still the gold standard of research and
that with metas sometimes you can just
get like a garbage in garbage out effect
you know smaller like spurious findings
from like spurious findings from small
sample research you know maybe you have
some publication bias which is like
mudding the body of literature
especially if you're dealing with small
trials and so it was looking at it was
looking at the rates at which meta
analyses conducted on a collection of
small studies differed and results from
subsequently published very large RCTs I
think mostly looking at medical stuff
like drug trials and it found that like
man I wish I had it in front of me but a
non-negligible amount of the time maybe
like thirty forty percent of the time
large well-conducted RCTs would come to
different results than metas on like
relatively small samples so i I do
largely agree with you if you have a
well conducted meta with largely good
high-quality studies going into it
that's probably worth paying more mind
to than a single well conducted you know
individual study that is of comparable
quality to the stuff that's already in a
meta or you know the other things in a
meta that it is also included and but I
I would I would just like to add that
like little bit of nuance there that
sometimes one particularly well
conducted study can be more valuable
than maybe like a garbage in garbage out
type meta like I definitely don't think
that's what's going on here but that III
think that I think a lot of people have
too quick of a knee-jerk reaction to
just go with a meta like over a very
well conducted RCT and I don't think
that's a terrible heuristic but it's not
I don't think it's the right way to go
in all circumstances all the time yeah
well I mean you know when you're when
you're working your way through a meta
you know certainly I want to look at the
stuff
that are going into it and you say okay
well this one was done extremely
meticulously with a huge sample and has
really good dosing guidelines for the
supplement and all the other ones are
little piece of crap studies that were
done poorly and had stupid outcomes and
really low doses of the active
ingredient yeah at that point you're
gonna say I don't I don't want to
contaminate the good results with all
this crap in there you know so so
absolutely that is true in the case of
this particular meta-analysis the lead
author was Hugh and it was published in
2019 this one had 13 trials included
with a total of over a hundred and
twenty seven thousand subjects so on
average they were pretty large trials
going into this but what they found by
aggregating the results from from all
these trials going into it actually a
cool thing they did was they removed
this one study that was particularly
impressive with regard to the magnitude
of effects that it found so they did a
bit of a sensitivity analysis you know
like we're talking about they wanted to
make sure that one particular study
wasn't really pulling all the results in
one direction so even without that study
and this one was looking at fish oil
specifically here they did find small
but statistically significant benefits
when it comes to the rate of myocardial
infarctions carta death related to a
coronary heart disease total coronary
heart disease cardiovascular disease
death and total cardiovascular disease
and you know we're talking about rate
ratios above 0.9 okay with 1.0 being no
effect at all so these are not huge and
the confidence intervals are all kind of
flirting with that 1.0 number what what
they did find as well in this particular
study was obviously they added in that
additional study and the effects got
even more pronounced but you know you
got to be careful about how much you
want to really consider those results
when you know there's that huge outlier
kind of pulling those values but they
did find a statistically significant
dose response relationship and so what
the
found was you know the larger the fish
oil doses were the more protective they
appeared to be for some of these
cardiovascular health outcomes now I do
want to be clear the the there have been
big reviews and meta-analyses on this
topic that have come out with equivocal
findings basically they're like okay
well the official didn't do anything bad
but it didn't really help much at all
and so I don't want to present this as
if it's a closed case like definitely
fish oil major preventive effect on
heart disease and related outcomes
however you know I think what's really
important when it comes to fish oil is
remembering why you would bother
okay so omega-3 fatty acids are
essential in the diet we have to have
dietary sources of omega-3s and
particularly the marine omega-3s are
quite quite effective in terms of their
physiological function we we want to
make sure we're getting epa and DHA and
frankly we're pretty terrible at
converting ala to to those to those
other omega-3s to epa and DHA and so we
want to make sure that we're getting
some source of epa and DHA and the diet
if we can and you know so if you're
eating plenty of fish i would not expect
a really meaningful health effect from
fish oil supplementation but if you're
somebody who doesn't eat really any
fatty fish when i look at the the
potential pros and cons of including a
fish oil supplement it seems like you
know within a reasonable dosing it's
like you don't have much to lose there
and it might have some small positive
effect and frankly the oume the the
marine derived omega-3s are just awesome
when you when you look at their roles in
the eyes and the brain and there's
several different different tissues
throughout the body and different organ
systems it makes sense to me to make
some effort effort to get marine
omega-3s into the diet whether you're
getting it from a few servings of fatty
fish a week or whether you're getting it
from a sensibly dosed fish oil
supplement now there are you know when
people think of marine derived omega-3s
they always think fish oil it is
important to note that there are
some vegan sources of marine derived
omega-3s a lot of times people on vegan
or vegetarian diets that that you know
people that don't eat fish a lot of
times they'll go for a la sources of
omega-3 so they'll go for like flaxseed
chia seed hemp seeds I've seen a lot
more products lately using algae and
seaweed which apparently actually do
contain EPA and DHA in them and so at
face value that seems to me like it'd
probably be a preferable approach rather
than going with ala because like I said
that conversion from ala is pretty
inefficient for for humans so I'm kind
of putting all the literature on omega-3
together like I said I there there have
been some results going either way there
have been some mixed results in the
research I think the the kind of
baseline starting point for is it worth
it it's a supplement with omega-3s
specifically fish derived or marine
derived omega-3s I'd say if you're not
getting plenty of omega-3s in the diet
if you're not eating fatty fish or some
other source of these marine omega-3s
it makes sense to at least supplement a
little bit I wouldn't expect any
particularly huge effects but I just
can't see what it would hurt in theory
now there have been some studies looking
at fish oil basically saying like oh it
has these effects on fat oxidation or
anabolic or catabolic signaling and
those are gonna have big effects on
muscle mass and body composition I am
much more skeptical about those
particular outcomes you know there are
some studies showing these little
mechanistic effects that that seem like
they might be notable but when you look
at the research actually evaluating body
compound comes in healthy people it
really doesn't seem to pan out in a
particularly impressive way so if you're
thinking I'm gonna get on fish oil
because it's gonna have a tangible
impact on my physique or my performance
I'd say probably not well I only if it's
flame out I've never heard of that in my
life
what flame out isn't that the the bio
test brand omega-3 supplement I know
people used to swear by it for getting
huge back in the day I mean I'm
completely joking like I don't think
that it it in it alone is like the one
ohm a
three that'll get get you huge but I
know that that's like that's the Train
everyone was on back in like oh six okay
yeah I miss that train but yeah it
wasn't a particularly good train as far
as trains go you know it wasn't one of
those like high-speed bullet trains just
you know kind of like a standard train
lots of carbon emissions just right
chugging along yeah so like I said EPA
and DHA have important roles in the body
you're gonna want to get it somewhere if
you're not eating fatty fish or some
other kind of source of it a supplement
makes sense but I wouldn't expect it to
have some huge effect on certainly not
on your physique and even the magnitude
of the effects on these different
cardiovascular risks is small I think
that's fair to say now vitamin D I
actually just reviewed a vitamin D
meta-analysis it was by Hahn and
colleagues I reviewed it in Mass this
past month and boy oh boy Greg you said
not to be oh and not to have too much
faith in metas so this is an example I
actually as mass readers will know I
just recalculated it I didn't like how
they handled it I found some errors so I
just kind of I just kind of redid it so
yeah your your advice to be to still
proceed with caution with meta analyses
I definitely agree with that
but in any case I you know when you look
at the vitamin D literature a lot of
studies they specifically look at older
populations or clinical populations
which from a public health perspective
makes all the sense in the world right
but we're selfish and we want to get
jacked so what was cool about this meta
analysis is it actually looked
specifically at athletes looking at how
vitamin D supplementation affected
strength performance so and when it
comes to the health stuff like vitamin D
it's a vitamin you want your levels to
be normal like that's about as far as I
want to get into it in terms of like
long-term health outcomes I know the
vital study was specifically looking at
cardiovascular risk and looking at
cancer risk I'm no cardiologist or
oncologist but generally speaking if
something's a vitamin you'd want to not
be deficient in it is my general default
for good health but but I figure a lot
of people listening probably do have an
interest in the performance effects of
vitamin D because back in the day you
know a few years ago vitamin D I think
was really popular in lifters because
you see these studies and there actually
is a decent amount of of healthy people
and even healthy athletes who are
walking around with blood vitamin D
levels that are considered insufficient
or even deficient and so that caught a
lot of people's of at the attention of a
lot of lifters and also there are
several realistic mechanisms by which we
could expect a vitamin D to play some
supportive role in neuromuscular
functions so I think a lot of people in
the lifting world looked at it and said
okay vitamin D relates to my strength
and muscle gains and a lot of people
seem to be deficient in it so I better
get on it and so this meta-analysis
looked at different supplement vitamin D
supplement interventions looking at
strength outcomes when I wreak runch the
numbers it basically included studies
looking at one or two outcomes so they
were either looking at isokinetic knee
extension performance or benchpress
benchpress performance the overall
effect size was a Cohen's D value it was
actually hedges G but but they're
interpreted in a similar way of 0.2
which is like small but first
supplements small small effects are like
the name of the game basically the
p-value was 0.34 but it was at least
enough to say okay well that's kind of
interesting where it got even more
interesting was if you break it up
the benchpress results had a D value of
negative 0.12
but for leg extension the isokinetic leg
extension the effect size was 0.63 and
that was statistically significant
a couple trends that jumped out from the
data the largest effects for vitamin D
supplementation unsurprisingly were
observed in the samples who started out
with the lowest blood vitamin D levels
and that that seems to line up pretty
well with what I mentioned in those the
the vital study how they they were like
okay there seemed to be some protective
effect particularly in the people who
had really low intakes of fish right so
it goes to that point of when we look at
these things as supplements the whole
point is to just make up for a
deficiency in the diet so we're not
taking things like fish oil and vitamin
D to become more than human and you know
ascend to the next level of being we're
taking them because it's like oh [ __ ] I
haven't been eating any fish I should
probably get those fatty acids right
same thing with vitamin D oh my levels
are low I might want to jump on that to
get them into the normal range yeah so
we're just correcting deficiencies here
we're not we're not expecting anything
particularly shocking in terms of
results another trend like I mentioned
there appeared to be a difference
between upper body and lower body
outcomes but I did some digging through
the rest of the literature I don't think
that has anything to do with how muscles
work I I really believe that that is
purely a methods issue and so uh you
know when they look at the bench press
it's a blunt measurement most studies
most strength labs don't really have
like micro plates where they can do
really really small increments and bench
press even if you did with bench press
you kind of have to like when you're
when you're guessing the one rep max
increments you have to be pretty good at
it and get a true max before you fatigue
the participant which and it kind of
depends how strong someone is yeah if
someone's if someone benches somewhere
around 3:15 and you know maybe they
could have gotten 318 but they fail 320
you're still pretty close you know
you're you're about one percent off but
if it's a like untrained females and
you're dealing with someone who you know
they get 60 pounds they fail 65 but they
could have done 64 at that point you're
how much is that it's it's a
non-negligible percentage off right it's
like it's like six and a half percent so
yeah like it depends what what
population you're dealing with but yeah
for sure only being able to do like two
and a half or five pound increments can
definitely lead to poor precision in
some applications yeah and there's
there's also you'd like to pretend there
aren't but there are some psychological
factors as well usually in a benchpress
study people are going to know what they
did
the pretest I mean they can typically
see the plates and so a lot of people
with a pre/post design they don't want
their bench to go down they want it to
go up and so you have to be really
really vigilant when you're running a
study like that that you are getting a
100% legitimate maximal effort on all
visits and making sure that they're not
kind of sandbagging that first visit or
tapping into some like superhuman level
of motivation for that post visit
because they want to beat their pre but
in any case if you compare that to
something like isokinetic leg extension
it's like first of all you can adjust
every part of that machine to
standardize the movement perfectly I
mean you can adjust the hip angle the I
mean I mean I've used these leg
extension dynamometer before the number
of adjustments you can make I think you
can jot down probably somewhere between
nine and twelve different settings for
each person's chair placement like it's
absolutely insane the number of things
you can adjust to make it a perfectly
repeatable exercise a hundred percent
they also have no idea how much they're
moving unless you tell them like they
won't know the Newton meters they put
out unless you tell them and so there's
a lot of benefits and it can be a
precise number of Newton meters like
like we said we don't have to hope we're
within five pound increments we can get
a really nice precise measurement down
to the exact Newton meter so when you
look at the the really really precise
strength measurements that have been
taken in this literature there does seem
to be a small effect of vitamin D when
you look at the less precise
measurements that effect seems to wash
out at least now that was my take
looking through the literature I think
that's that's fair and at minimum very
plausible yeah maybe I'm wrong maybe
maybe there's something really special
about the lower body musculature that's
totally different but I think the most
parsimonious explanation comes down to
testing is it theorized or has it been
observed that vitamin D affects any sort
of like neural variables because I know
that there's I know that there's some
stuff and like the the neuromuscular
fatigue literature that indicates that
like
mechanisms of fatigue and the ability to
activate motor units differ to some
degree between upper and lower body
we're essentially like if you're dealing
with if you're dealing with like central
fatigue or just kind of like
psychological but non-physical fatigue
that could impact lower body performance
much more so than upper body and so like
who knows maybe like vitamin D has
something to do with that if it's having
some sort of effects on the nervous
system could just be that like the lower
body is a little bit more sensitive to
that even just me saying this right now
that that feels to me like a bit of a
reach so the reason that I didn't go all
the way down that route when I was
trying to figure this out is a couple
main studies there was one big study
with cross sectional strength data where
they did upper and lower body
measurements all using dynamometer II
and in that study the upper body and
lower body relationship with with
vitamin D and strength it was the same
for upper body and lower body if not you
could actually make the argument it was
a little bit more reliable in the upper
body than the lower body so it
definitely went against that concept
that it's having a bigger purport
proportionately stronger effect on the
lower body musculature from a
physiological perspective once that
sensitivity of measurement is kind of
equated the other thing that really
pushed me over the top for justification
was there was a different meta-analysis
that involve included several other
studies and so for the upper body and
lower body it was that the one where
they included hand grip strength I think
yeah okay some of it was it was by
Tomlinson I think yeah yeah and so the
upper body and lower body looking at
each of them independently there tended
to be more notable effects with
dynamometer II based measurements and
then when they used kind of more blunt
measurements with free weights or
machines then the the effects seem to
really wash away whether you were
looking at upper body or lower body so
make sense all all of that combined I
wouldn't say certainly that there's not
a physiological rationale but I
think them the simplest and most
evidence-based at this point explanation
probably comes down to testing method
make sense if I had to choose one or the
other so when it comes to vitamin D one
thing to keep in mind there is a bit of
a debate regarding what a sufficient
level is so some people say that that
blood levels of 25 Oh H D which is like
this simple blood vitamin D test that
gets done most but most frequently some
people say it should be above 20
nanograms per milliliter which is 15
animals per liter I hate this this is
one of those one of those things where
they don't agree on the units some
people use one some use the other which
just make makes things unnecessarily
complicated other people suggest that it
should be above 30 nanograms per
milliliter which is 75 in animals per
liter and so I don't know if vitamin D
experts have finally gotten together
recently and sorted this out but I would
say it makes sense to shoot for the
higher one because frankly I mean you're
not anywhere near toxicity levels if you
meet the lower end of that of that
higher range so 75 and animals per liter
if from my perspective I see no downside
to shooting for that as you're just like
safe bet in terms of blood vitamin D
levels now it there there is some
potential that you could achieve
toxicity because it is a fat-soluble
vitamin so I do recommend if you want to
go the vitamin D route like the
theoretically the best option is to get
with a health care provider get with
your doctor or whatever get your blood
levels tested and get on a supplement
plan with them have them guide you
through it it's kind of like a TR T kind
of thing where if like if you're on like
Realty RT and you don't just want like a
steroids prescription but if you're like
below the normal test range they don't
just say I don't know go find some
testosterone and give it a shot they say
okay let's get you on a plan and we'll
we'll handle the dosing and get you into
the normal range there's like an
observation process
that that is guided by that health care
practitioner I think that's the best bet
with vitamin D now a lot of times people
wonder well who should be taking vitamin
D they vitamin D levels tend to be lower
in people who have minimal direct
exposure to sunlight live at high out
high latitudes or frequently wear a lot
of sunblock like really strong some
sunblock now a lot of times you'll hear
that people with darker skin
pigmentation have lower vitamin D levels
and that is true for 2500hd
concentrations in the blood but people
have done more research like in the last
few years and what they're finding is
that that the 2500hd test might not be
the best test for people who do have
darker skin pigmentation and when they
look at the more bioavailable portion of
blood vitamin D levels with a slightly
different test they do find that despite
having lower total levels of 2500hd
some people with darker skin
pigmentation actually do have a
completely sufficient amount of
bioactive vitamin D so again it's the
kind of thing that if you're concerned
about it it's probably best to get with
a health care professional who who knows
what they're doing so they can get you
on the right track there so again some
summarizing things here whether you're
talking about fish oil at war or vitamin
D these are you know you want your
vitamin D to be in normal ranges you
want to be getting sufficient marine
derived omega-3s from your diet and if
your diet alone is not taking care of
these things I think supplementation
makes a lot of sense but if you're
totally sufficient with these things I
would not expect that supplementation
with either of them is gonna have a
meaningful effect either when it comes
to your performance your body
composition or as the original question
mentioned your health outcomes make
sense
cool that was a long one I feel like I
talked for a long time yeah you did yeah
okay I had virtually nothing to add well
you were mentioning the question where
are you that's a shame well I mean he
addressed it to both of us but I wasn't
gonna touch that with a 10-foot Pole
yeah that's fair
so one random fact about if you for
whatever reason very full heartedly
decided to take mega doses of vitamin D
every day without a need to I don't
think any research on that exists in
humans because why would it you would be
very hard to clear that by by an IRB
because you know mega dosing
fat-soluable vitamins you don't readily
flush out could have very negative
adverse effects but one one potential
side effect of super super like crazy
high vitamin D intakes potentially is a
very significant amount of fatty acid
infiltration of the muscles or like
adipose tissue inflammation of the
muscles so that's what happens when you
mega dose cows with a vitamin D that's
one of the things they do to two cows
when they're trying to fatten them up
okay before they're slaughtered like I I
don't think it's super common but there
is like research and in the livestock
literature looking at vitamin D mega
dosing cattle so the there's at least I
mean I don't think I'm not claiming that
for sure happens in humans but there is
at least some reason to suspect that it
could potentially happen so yeah it's
not smart don't don't mega dose fat
soluble vitamins if there's a dietary
effect in a cow why wouldn't it apply to
you that would be my counter question
well I mean I'm not going to pretend
like I know all of the aspects of
vitamin D metabolism in humans much less
cattle well that was just me throwing
back to my egregious miss quotes
regarding game-changers oh yeah if it
works for the cow much to work for you
yeah I need to let that go how do they
do the the is it foie gras the fatty
liver oh that's how do they do that it's
D it's disgusting and deeply unethical
they just force feed the baby goose they
force-feed it
I'm pretty sure they intubated oh man
yeah that's messed up yeah I've never
had it I mean I didn't grow up bougie
but you know I saw that it was used in a
lot of like bougie dishes and I was like
oh you know maybe at some point if I
feel like splurging see what vlog wah is
like and then I figured out what it was
and how they went about producing it and
said no that's I mean I'm not that much
of a tree hugger
like I'm not like a radical vegan or
anything like that but as far as like
animal welfare goes in in the food
supply that's that's definitely a line
that I feel like shouldn't be crossed
yeah I've never had it I've never I've
never even seen it like on a menu or at
the store but I knew it existed and I
knew it was gross and it's it's family
fatty liver yeah is basically it right
but yeah your comment on how they do
that to cows got me wondering I was like
how do they do that again yeah it's I
mean it's essentially torture god it's
awful okay let's move on to some wider
topics we just [ __ ] up this
Valentine's episode I know we really
blew it sorry guys okay we've got a
question from fit by psy hopefully you
guys blew it before we got to this part
of the episode that's that's terrible
okay we're leaving it in if I was born
with poor lifting genes but I continued
lifting just because I like it and then
I give birth to a child who inherited my
poor genes but they also lifted just
because they liked it how many
generations of children is it going to
take before my family now has good
lifting genes so that's a good question
it could be as few as one so you know
it's going to depend on you know who
your children marry and whether their
spouses have good genetics for lifting
because you know that that can sort
itself out pretty quickly just speaking
anecdotally here
for myself my father I think has
considerably below average genetics for
resistance training he he didn't do it
until he was already older like in his
50s but you know he he does resistance
training now does some squats does some
bench press I think he still does
deadlifts I'm not sure about that but
you know does he does the damn thing has
it has a weight set in the basement and
you know I'm proud of the guy is like
since he started exercising more both
resistance training and like doing more
cardio like he did a half marathon
recently which like I thought was super
super cool he was a really good
cross-country runner in high school but
like basically didn't run for like
thirty years so like super proud of him
for getting back in that kind of shape
and like I said he's been doing some
lifting he's been doing some lifting as
well and I don't know I'm not gonna I'm
not gonna tell the entire Internet my
father's numbers but they're not
impressive they're whatever you're
thinking they're probably lower however
you know I clearly turned out ok got
reasonably strong I'm still reasonably
strong and a lot of that is because my
mother was [ __ ] insane like
incredibly strong and that that entire
side of the family my mom's whole side
of the family everyone even most of the
people who've never trained are super
strong and all of the ones who have
trained are super super strong like
there's there's multiple 500-pound bench
pressors and 800 pound deadlift errs on
that side of the family now most of them
are you know six somewhere between six
three and six eight and very large so I
didn't I didn't get that part of the
gene line you know my father cutting his
very below average strength genetics
with my mother's very exceptional
strength genetics worked out pretty
pretty okay for me so you know it's
going to depend a lot on on spouse
selection and and whether you know those
spouses give the children good genes I
like how you say spouse reinforce
those good family values it's not made
it's got to be it's got to be through
marriage well yeah okay yeah that's
potentially discriminatory just whoever
they decide to copulate with there you
go anyway so another thing I would say
as well is when people don't respond
super well to training their knee jerk
reaction I think is to assume that they
have bad genetics which isn't a terrible
assumption because most of the heritable
and and difficult in poorly malleable
traits about yourself are likely due to
genes at least to some degree or another
but another thing to keep in mind is
environment matters a lot and so not
just like you know your current house
and neighborhood and whatnot but
environments such as
in in utero to environments or like
early childhood upbringing like there's
a lot of epigenetic changes and
modifications that go on during infancy
and early childhood that are malleable
but more difficult to change in
adulthood so you know you very well may
not get great results in the gym but
maybe that's due to you know some Epogen
epigenetic modifications due to you're
like in utero or early childhood
environments that if you're you know if
your kids have your same genes or very
very similar genes but like a different
in utero and early childhood environment
they're they very well may end up more
responsive to resistance training on
that topic interestingly there was a
review published recently titled impact
of parental exercise on epigenetic
modifications inherited by offsprings a
systematic review and so it was a
systematic review but I'm pretty sure it
only included four studies so you know
it's not like there's been a ton of work
in this area yet but the stuff that's
out there does indicate that essentially
if
you do all the quote-unquote right stuff
if you exercise if you eat well benefits
of that will likely be passed on to your
children so you know whatever genes you
have assuming your children have similar
genes but you know you take better care
of yourself and like they have a better
uterine environment and a better early
childhood environment and like
upbringing to be conducive to getting
big and strong their you know the way
that they respond to training very well
could be considerably better than yours
even with just even with similar actual
genetic makeups so anyway yeah I mean
the the thing that's going to matter
more than more than anything else by far
is just you know if you have shitty
genes and your kids have shitty genes
but then your kids procreate with
someone with exceptional genes you know
you might be looking at one generation
to really turn that around but you know
just you trying to be responsible and
give your kids the best an environment
that is conducive to training
responsiveness which I'm going to assume
is you know not letting them become
obese and early childhood and making
sure that they're active and play sports
and whatnot
that will probably help them as well I
think that there's probably a I think
there's probably a wall that you can hit
with just that strategy so you know
ultimately Darwin was correct and not
Lamarck
um so you know there is probably like a
hard limit that you could get with just
epigenetic modifications but you know
it's probably not nothing so yeah that's
a I like the premise of this question we
were talking about this looking over
that line before we started recording
this guy's thinking like you know I I
want to get what I can out of this but
you know in the year 3000 I want my
great-great-great-great
great-great-great-great
children to be [ __ ] jacked right and
I like that that's that's good long-term
thinking you pass the marshmallow test
with flying colors and hopefully can
pass it for you know for all of your
offspring as well but it's like planting
a tree you're not doing it for yourself
you're doing it for the next generation
correct which is really admirable yeah
so I'm just wondering how that could
possibly work logistically like maybe
for your inheritance you could write
something into it like okay so here's
what you got to do at fit by side so you
need to make your fortune you know you
need to make a few billion dollars
enough that it's going to be like a huge
nest egg for generations to come
you need to put that in escrow and you
need to have a stipulation that like
your direct blood blood relatives can
inherit that money but only if they are
verifiably resistance training enough so
you know if they're not hitting the gym
for a couple hours three or four times a
week they're not seeing a penny of that
so in order for this plan to work for
this to not just be purely theoretical
you need to make sure you have a big
enough carrot that you can dangle out
there for you know at least a few score
years to really pull this plan off so
that's probably what I recommend first
and foremost here perfect yeah very
applicable very pragmatic it's good okay
moving on Matt asks Eric our standing
desks scientifically better for athletes
than sitting all day and how is that
quantifiable thinking about converting
my office set up to standing but don't
want to waste money yeah that's a good
question so a lot of times when people
bring up the concept of standing desks
one of the things that comes up a lot is
energy expenditure and they're like well
if I'm standing at my desk instead of
sitting theoretically I'm burning more
calories throughout the day that should
either help me get leaner or should
allow me to stay you know the same body
fat percentage while eating more and
both of those a lot of people view is a
good thing so I wanted to address that
based on a study I found from
17 lead author's name was Gibbs and they
basically just looked at energy
expenditure over a one-hour period they
did in direct calorimetry to to measure
how many calories participants were
burning in in three different conditions
so they either were just doing their
desk work for an hour just sitting at
their desk or they did 30 minutes of
sitting in 30 minutes of standing or
they did the full hour standing and what
they basically found here was compared
with sitting the combination of standing
and sitting gave them an additional 5.5
calories per hour so it increased their
energy expenditure by about seven or
eight percent now compared to sitting if
you stood the whole hour that increased
energy expenditure by about eight
calories per hour which was about an 11
or 12 percent increase so what that what
they calculated was if they just kind of
alternated positions throughout the day
to give them four hours day of standing
that would ultimately throughout a
workday translate to about 40 or 50
calories day or I should say 40 50 to 60
calories per day burnt depending on how
big you are depending on your body size
they also looked at a few additional
outcomes they looked at heart rate
productivity and self-reported energy
fatigue and pain for all of those
outcomes they didn't find anything that
was predict particularly notable so in
terms of the energy expenditure I mean
if you view standing at your desk as
being a huge pain I mean we're talking
about if you increase your standing time
by four hours a day by using this
strategy we're talking about an extra
like fifty calories that that's really
not a ton so it's not a particularly
effective strategy for that now that
doesn't mean there's no benefit
whatsoever of breaking up your your
completely sedentary time but you know a
couple things to keep in mind are
subjectively like I've used standing
desks for periods of time for certain
tasks I find it I almost am
able to kind of lock in and focus better
when I'm standing but for other tasks
I'm like I gotta sit for this and I know
that's weird I know it's totally
anecdotal but it's something to keep in
mind like when if you're using this desk
to do like your work which is important
like you have to make sure that you're
putting your you're setting yourself up
to be productive and focused while
you're working that's gonna be way more
important than 40 or 50 calories per day
another thing to keep in mind so like
I've you standing desk before in the
past not because I was like oh man I
gotta burn some calories or break up my
sedentary sitting time but because my
back frickin hurt like my back or my hip
or something and I was like I can't keep
sitting in a chair it's killing me and
so for it there are reasons why you
might implement like an adjustable
standing vs. seated desk but I would not
expect it to have a huge impact on your
daily energy expenditure there there
have been some studies like in the world
of public health where they look at
other options where they basically say
like every so often throughout the day
take a walk around the floor like at
your workplace just to break up your
sedentary time if the point was to break
up sedentary time and the point was to
increase energy expenditure throughout
the day I would personally lean toward a
more mobile option of breaking up that
sedentary time so you know if you've got
a stairwell in the workplace when you
can afford to take a minute away from
your work if that's possible go do a
couple flights of stairs and get back
into it so that's kind of how I would
view it and then another thing to add as
well is there there has been research
looking at whether sedentary time is is
bad is associated with the deleterious
health effects independent of exercise
so basically you know if you sit for 12
hours a day but then 2 hours a day you
really get after it in the gym and
exercise very intensely can you will you
still are you still likely to see
negative effects from that sedentary
time and it does appear that yes time
spent sitting or lying down and I guess
specifically time spent sitting mostly
during the workday or during
you know time when you're home from work
but not asleep does does seem to be
independently associated with
deleterious health effects even when
accounting for time span exercise yeah I
that was my understanding of the
literature as well my gut reaction
though I got a feel like some kind of
ambulation is probably even more
effective for breaking up that sedentary
time than just standing stationary oh
for sure
I would have to think so so personally I
think that would the way I would view it
personally would be I'm gonna work in
whatever posture allows me to be
pain-free comfortable and focused on my
work and if I am gonna break up that set
in Terry time I'm probably going to if
possible opted for a quick walk around
the building a quick walk up and down a
flight of stairs a couple times you know
whatever you can whatever you're able to
get in I think would probably be the
best option if you're if you're
interested in overhauling say like a
home office and you're thinking you you
may be willing to spend a fair amount of
money
it may not be a terrible idea to look
into a treadmill desk either so I know
that there's some literature looking at
learning so like encoding information
and like when you're either sedentary or
engaging in very light physical activity
and it seems like you do learn a little
bit more efficiently and effectively
if you are like undergoing light
physical activity so the the study that
springs to mind and so the the reason
this is on my mind is when I went to
college I was a history major and
history is [ __ ] hard so like when I
transferred to exercise science that was
that was the best decision I ever made
for mental health because exercise
science classes were so much easier than
history classes just like the sheer
amount of information you had to learn
for like as a history major was was
immense and so I had never had trouble
learn just you know just learning enough
facts
to keep up in class before and then when
I went to college my first semester I
was taking like for like four or five
pretty challenging upper-level history
classes and it I realized within a
couple weeks like oh [ __ ] this very well
may kick my ass and so I got online and
I was like what are things that I can
use to learn more efficiently so like
you know I only have to look at this
material two or three times to get it
locked down pretty well instead of five
or six times and I came across some
research looking at language acquisition
and I believe school-aged children's
like you know 15 16 year-old kids where
they had them try to learn new words and
and I believe in a foreign language
either sitting or just walking slowly on
a treadmill and they they learned like
god I haven't read this study in over a
decade so I don't remember any of the
details maybe I should have been walking
when I was reading it but it was it was
a non-negligible difference in the rate
that they were able to both learn and
retain that information and so I said
like well [ __ ] it I'm gonna give this a
shot and so I did all of my reading and
studying for class in like the student
gym I just hop on a treadmill set it to
like a mile and a half two miles an hour
really slow and just do all of my
reading and studying there and just
anecdotally I personally found it to be
super super helpful and beneficial I
retained information a lot better I
found myself getting better grades while
studying slightly less so your mileage
may vary but if you're if you're already
looking into standing desks and and so
again I'm basing this off of like three
studies that I found when I was a
freshman in college and didn't know [ __ ]
about the scientific method so the
overall state of the literature now
could be completely different just
throwing that out there as a caveat but
if you are thinking about changing your
desk situation I would personally
recommend at least looking into that
body of literature because treadmill
desks before the investment may kind of
give you more than just
standing desks would or they could not
and you know three studies I pulled up
when I was 18 could be completely wrong
now who knows we'll never know but the
nice thing about the standing desk
option is it can be so easy to do and so
like for me there have been times where
due to various you know back or hip pain
or whatever it is I've opted to do some
part of the workday standing I will say
this it can get pre your legs can tire
out if you stand for for that long and
so that's something to keep in mind
that's the thing with me
I find that my legs get way less tired
if I'm walking really slow than if I'm
just standing in place yeah so like
there were days where I'd like stand for
much of the work day and then go hit a
sick leg day in the gym and it wasn't so
sick alright you wanna move on to the
research roundup yeah let's do it
cool alright so I've got I'm gonna try
to get through these kind of quickly we
are running a bit long on time here I
have had no fewer than 10 people
formally request that we put out for our
episodes since we're only doing them
every other week now well that's a lot
of hours we're not running as long as
some people wish we were yeah it can be
kind of tiring to talk for two and a
half hours though it kind of is like I'm
pretty beat actually like I mean we
could go we could go to one podcast
direction where you just kind of talk
about whatever you feel like and don't
have any evidence to back it up and
don't have to like do background
research we could talk about that stuff
for like four hours
but this tick kind of takes work I mean
we're still going strong let's just see
what happens let's see what happens okay
so I promised this one last episode this
is the study looking at different kinds
of protein plant versus dairy based and
so the title is called differential
responses of blood essential amino acid
levels following ingestion of
high-quality plant based protein blends
compared to whey protein a double-blind
randomized crossover clinical trial so
this was by Brennan and colleagues in
2019 and so when we eat a meal with
protein
the post-meal increase in leucine plays
an important role in stimulating muscle
protein synthesis and thereby inducing
you know the growth and or maintenance
of muscle tissue and then similarly
plasma essential amino acids play an
important role in supporting that
process so the leucine is really the
trigger that initiates the process but
you do want to make sure you have plenty
of essential amino acids around in the
blood to support that now the authors of
this study this one was fascinating it's
one of those ones where you read it and
you read the results and you're like
what happened and then you like really
want to dig into the discussion you know
what I mean where there's no hypothesis
that immediately jumps to mind at least
not for me but what they do is they
compared these different different types
of protein and they looked at how they
affected post-meal amino acid levels so
they either took whey protein or three
different plant based protein blends
here's where it gets interesting so all
for the treatments had the same total
amount of leucine essential amino acids
and they had a protein digestibility
corrected amino acid score of one so
they did a lot of work to equate these
proteins on some of the key factors that
we would think aren't important for
these post a post meal amino acid
responses so as a result of that the
plant proteins required a total protein
dose around 33 or 34 grams while the way
dose was only 24 total grams because
they had they didn't have to do as many
workarounds to try to make that way kind
of equate with the others so in in the
four hours after feeding now all the
proteins did cause a notable increase in
plasma levels of leucine and essential
amino acids
but despite equating all of those
factors the whey protein values were
significantly and I would even say
substantially higher than the three
other proteins so the bright side if
you're really into plant-based proteins
are that these three appeared to be safe
well tolerated
and they did cause the the increase in
plasma leucine and plasma essential
amino acids that you would be looking
for but what was interesting was despite
all their efforts to equate those
various factors the way was still
superior in terms of the magnitude of
those amino acid responses and when I
read that I was like why and so they did
a really nice job in the discussion kind
of talking through some of the potential
factors so you know there are
nutritional components of a lot of
plant-based proteins the ones they
particularly out pointed out where
things like phytates
tannins and trypsin inhibitors that are
kind of just naturally there that could
potentially affect the digestibility and
the bioavailability of some of the amino
acids within those proteins they
mentioned that you can alter some of
these things by the level of hydrolysis
that you do to the protein so some like
enzymatic hydrolysis in the process of
preparing the protein but but they did
they basically said we did some mild
hydrolysis but apparently it just wasn't
enough to achieve a bio equivalent
effect compared to the whey protein and
they did note like yeah we could have we
could have gone a little bit more
extreme with the hydrolysis but that
usually results in changes in flavor and
bitterness that are pretty unfavorable
if you're trying to make a palatable
protein product so that was important
stuff to keep in mind they also went
through some literature I wasn't aware
of where they kind of compared the
postprandial or post meal amino acid
kinetics looking at plant derived
proteins versus dairy derived proteins
and so they pointed out a few studies
and I'll link the original study so
people can kind of follow up if they
have an interest in it but it looks like
based on the evidence they were
presenting in the discussion that some
plant-based proteins do tend to get
sequestered into tissues at different
rates than the dairy based protein so
for example that they talked about a
study where they found it was by
boss at all BOS and colleagues where
compared to milk amino acids the soy
amino acids were actually digested more
rapidly and more favorably directed
toward deamination pathways and and
directed toward liver protein synthesis
so favorably might not be the the good
word choice there but more like
preferentially directed and so what they
found was basically those amino acids
were getting digested at slightly
different rates and therefore being
utilized in different ways and
essentially less available for that post
meal sustained well I don't even want to
say sustained but the the magnitude of
that post meal increase in leucine and
essential amino acids but also obviously
you know they didn't get to as high of
Peaks and then even at later time points
were still lower than what you'd see in
the way the whey protein group so I
guess to kind of wrap things up I feel
like I always have to give these caveats
I have literally zero issues with with
plant-based proteins or plant-based
diets there's all sorts of good reasons
why somebody would would go for a vegan
diet but this really does come back to
that idea that it's important to to
really take a look at your protein
sources if you're avoiding all animal
products just to make sure that you're
getting all of your ducks in a row and
you're making sure that you are really
giving your body adequate protein
feedings and there's a great article I
know we've talked about it a great
article on the site it's stronger by
science calm about vegetarian and vegan
diets and one of the accommodations that
you'll probably want to make in a diet
that's totally devoid of animal products
you'll probably want to skew toward a
higher total protein intake and make
those meals have a little bit more
protein than you otherwise would if you
were eating animal protein so it doesn't
mean you know if you're vegetarian or
vegan that you're you're totally screwed
and your diets bad and you won't get
huge that there's there's all sorts of
people who are vegan that lift that have
incredible results we know it can be
done and the science backs that up as
well you'll just want to make sure that
you've you
done the best you can in terms of
arranging your diet specifically your
protein intake in an advantageous way
the one big caveat I do want to mention
before I forget with this study they
were looking at post-meal amino acid
levels in the blood so it does take a
little bit of extrapolation to say that
that's necessarily going to have a
notable effect on muscle protein
synthesis another step of extrapolation
to say that's necessarily going to
affect you know hypertrophy or muscle
protein balance over time so that's an
important caveat but but it does seem to
fall in line with other studies that
have looked at some of those those
outcomes specifically like muscle
protein synthesis there there are
several labs that have done research
showing that the you you can get you
can't induce the same magnitude a muscle
protein synthesis with those plant-based
proteins but it's probably gonna take a
higher dose in most cases alright and
you you've got a study to share here
right yeah so I just want to do a very
quick little research review on
proximity to failure and strength gains
so a couple months ago I wrote an
article and then also talked about on
the podcast the concept of quote unquote
effective reps and just generally
whether whether there's benefit to
training to failure or closer to failure
for for muscle growth but something that
I didn't discuss then was the degree to
which that matters for strength gains
and there have been so there were a
couple studies pretty high-quality
studies looking at this in 2017 and
there were recently two more studies
kind of on the same topic put out to
this month looking at kind of do you get
larger strength gains on a per set basis
from training closer to failure and kind
of can you maximize strength gains on a
per set basis staying really really far
from failure so I just wanted to talk
about that a little bit so a good place
to start would be a
meta-analysis by Davies the title was
effective training leading to repetition
failure on muscular strength a
systematic review and meta-analysis
there were kind of two sections of that
meta the he looked at both volume
equated and non volume equated studies
and basically found that within the
literature up to that point strength
gains were pretty similar whether or not
sets were taken to failure one thing to
note is if you do pull up that
meta-analysis there were some
statistical issues with it when it was
first published they since issued an
erratum so if you pull up the original
meta-analysis I think they conclude that
there are some differences either with
volume equator that are not equated but
when they reran the stats and did it the
right way they basically found like oh
[ __ ] we [ __ ] up there are no
differences here so that's a pretty good
place to start but that was just looking
at failure versus non failure training
not you know submaximal training not to
failure but just at different
proximities from failure and so kind of
within that world there's I guess one
researchers slash research a group worth
paying attention to here and that is
pareja Blanco so of these four studies
I'm gonna talk about I think he was the
lead author on two of them and the
senior author on two of them and so one
of them the title is the effects of
velocity loss during during body mass
prone grip pull up training on strength
and endurance performance that one was
just recently published this month
another one the title is low velocity
loss induces similar strength gains to
moderate velocity lost earned resistance
training that was also just published
this month and then the two published in
2017 one was effects of velocity lost
air and resistance training on athletic
performance strength gains and muscle
adaptations and then the other one the
last one was effects of velocity loss
Geron resistance training on performance
in professional soccer players and so
these studies were all slightly
different in in the way they went about
doing things but the the core
commonality between
them was they for the most part didn't
have people training to failure they did
hit failure for some of the sets in one
of the studies but for the most part
this was non failure training and they
were using percentage philosophy loss to
basically determine how far away from
failure people stayed and so when you're
doing velocity based training if you're
trying to move every rep as fast as
possible bar speed in rep speed is gonna
slow down as you get closer and closer
to failure importantly that takes place
pretty linearly not perfectly linearly
but pretty pretty close and so for
example if you wanted to squat and
you're starting with a pretty light load
that you can move at 1 meter per second
and you know you want to do a set where
you're you're doing a little something
but it's not particularly challenging
you're not going particularly close to
failure you could go with a 30 percent
velocity loss cutoff there so you would
do reps until your velocity device tells
you like oh you dip below point 7 meters
per second stop this set here or if you
wanted to go quite a bit closer to
failure you could have a velocity loss
threshold of 60% so you would do reps
until your velocity drop below point 4
meters per second and that would get you
quite a bit closer to failure so it's
it's not exactly the same thing as RP or
reps and reserve but it kind of
accomplishes the same thing I personally
like reps and reserve but it's it kind
of gets at the same concept it's using
it's using a measure to auto regulate
and keep you either further or closer to
failure and so in the in the recent
study that used pull ups the velocity
lost thresholds they used were 25
percent versus 50 percent so a 25
percent velocity loss and pull ups will
get you about half way to failure give
or take and a 50 percent velocity loss
will get you almost all the way to
failure but not quite there at least in
the population they were working with
who could do about 15 bodyweight
pull-ups give or take one of the other
studies they looked at it was using
squats with a
five versus 20% velocity loss threshold
a 5% velocity losses not much at all
you're accruing essentially no fatigue
if velocity is just decreasing 5% versus
20% like that's that's a fairly moderate
velocity loss the one from this group
that gets cited the most often I think
was also using squats and it was using a
20 versus 40 percent velocity loss
threshold this one included training up
to 85% of 1rm and a 40% velocity loss
with training that close to one RM is
generally going to result in failure so
in that group the 20% group never failed
the 40% group I think reached the point
of failure unlike 20 or 30 percent of
their total training sets and then the
other group or the other study was using
loads between 50 and 70 percent one RM
on squats in professional soccer players
with the 15 verse with 15 verses 30
percent philosophy lost thresholds 15
percent there is going to be a pretty
moderate like quite easy velocity loss
threshold 30% is is going to be still
fairly easy if you're training at 50
percent one RM and at 70 percent it's
going to start getting kind of
challenging but not particularly close
to failure so those are the four studies
they use different velocity loss
thresholds and consequently different
proximities to failure and all four of
them and all of them importantly here
matched four sets so they didn't match
for volume load or match for total reps
basically there was both both groups
would use the same intensity but one
group would just go a little bit closer
to failure and the other group would
stay further away from failure and they
did the same number of sets and in all
four of these studies there weren't
significant differences in strength
gains and in a couple of the studies
there were non significant differences
in strength games that actually leaned
in favor of the group staying a little
bit further away from failure that was
the case in the pull up study so the the
25% velocity loss pull-up group
put a little bit more on there estimated
pull-up 1rm than the 50% velocity loss
group in the 20 versus 40% velocity loss
squat study there was a non significant
difference leaning in favor of the 20%
velocity loss group and the same was
true in the 15 versus 30% velocity lost
squat study maybe slightly larger
strength gains in the 15% velocity loss
group so basically we have a
meta-analysis saying that like hey
whether or not training terminates in
failure or not doesn't really seem to
have much of an impact on performance
and here we have four more studies which
mostly were using two groups not
training to failure but still ik waiting
for sets finding pretty much the same
thing or maybe even it being slightly
better to stay even further away from
failure versus you know not going to
failure but pushing kind of close to
failure and so I think that I don't
think this is going to just
revolutionize the way I approach
training or coaching but it at least
opens me up to the idea more that kind
of like high reps in reserve or low RPE
work is maybe slightly more more useful
or beneficial than I had previously
given it credit for so I know that kind
of the way that I had thought about
training before like using reps and
Reserve or RPE is that like in RPE of
seven was seen as kind of like normal
training that's kind of on the easy side
eight was kind of like the default of
hey we're just gonna do a normal last
set this is probably gonna be sixty
percent of the training you do an RP of
nine or ten was considered pretty hard
and like yeah you don't want to do this
all the time but you know especially
like nine work you can do that fairly
frequently and save tens for you know
maybe once a week once a month
not super frequently that was just kind
of the conceptual schema I was working
with and in all of these studies the
lower velocity loss condition
have been training in an RP of like five
or six or below which at least in my
opinion like the way I always approach
training is like you know if you're at
an RPE of five if you have like five or
more reps in reserve
it's a [ __ ] warm-up set yeah I mean a
lot of times with clients that are D
loading I'll be like you know keep it
four or five and above you know but yeah
you wouldn't think that to be a
particularly stressful perturbation
correct and so in all of these studies
and and I'll note none of the subjects
in any of the studies or super elite
strength athletes by any means in the
twenty versus 40 percent velocity lost
squat study I think they had like some
decent degree of Train experience but
they weren't super strong the pull-up
study actually they were surprisingly
good at pull-ups like I said they were
averaging about fifteen bodyweight
pull-ups pre training which you know
that's not like an elite gymnast but
that's that's honestly not a bad pull-up
number but yeah they weren't super elite
so you know I'm I'm a little bit
hesitant to attempt to generalize but it
does at least open me up to the idea
that you know probably super low RP or
super high AR AR training probably still
isn't great as like the base of a
year-round program because I do think
that that's going to be too easy on a
per set basis to really cause much
muscle growth or and certainly it's not
going to be challenging enough on a per
set basis to maximize muscle growth so I
wouldn't really want that to be like the
core of like you know a month after
month year long type training program
but it does open me up to the idea that
if you are going into like a solely
strength focused block and you want to
make sure that training is as high of
quality as possible and you're not
accruing and accumulating a bunch of
fatigue that's gonna [ __ ] with your
performance in the gym you know maybe if
you would have been doing eighty percent
for sets of five maybe eighty percent
for sets of two or three is just as good
maybe even preferable in some
circumstances and then I was thinking
through the numbers I was like 80% for
doubles versus 80 percent for fives that
sounds a hell of a lot like what Boris
Shaco does that's I mean if you if you
pull up most Shaco programs that's
you're seeing a [ __ ] ton of doubles and
triples at 80% so maybe he was just way
ahead of the curve on this but yeah and
I think in terms of like a concrete
takeaway is if you're not too worried
about growth at the moment so there have
been I think we answered a question on
the last podcast of someone who is
really happy with the weight class
they're in and they don't you know
they're trying to get stronger without
putting on more muscle and I said yeah
you know maybe say a little bit further
away from failure and probably still get
some strength adaptations while
minimizing muscle growth that makes me
these studies make me feel a little bit
more confident in that recommendation
now that you know you probably can get
pretty good strength effects as long as
loading is appropriate while still
stayin quite far from failure and I
think another place where this where
this information could be useful is
people who are having trouble recover
like significant trouble recovering from
strength work that they do whether that
be because like you know you're just the
type of person that if you go above 80
percent of your max you start getting
worn down pretty quickly like that isn't
super common but happens to to a
non-negligible amount of people or you
know maybe your life's just super busy
you can't get in bed that much work is
stressful you have a lot of family [ __ ]
going on
you know life happens and you're having
difficulty recovering from heavier
training closer to failure strength is a
bigger goal for you you don't have huge
hypertrophy aspirations maybe a way that
you can still at least in the short to
moderate term get pretty good strength
effects while being able to dramatically
cut back on the amount of stress you're
accumulating like in each training
session would just be to you know
basically take your current program take
the percentages you're gonna be training
with take the number of sets you would
have otherwise been doing and just like
knock two or three reps off of all of
them
stay quite a bit further from failure
it's gonna make your workouts a lot
easier probably not gonna grow much from
it but at least in terms of strength
effects again in the short to moderate
term should work pretty well that's
that's at least an idea that I am kind
of more open to than than I think I was
previously before looking at this
literature it's interesting stuff all
right so I have a little research
roundup here a couple recent studies on
artificial sweeteners and the reason I'm
talking about this topic I actually did
get a kind of related question in the
Q&A submission portal so uh cavada asked
a little bit about artificial sweeteners
where do they fit in when it comes to
weight loss do they have any negative
effects other than dental health is what
the question said I was under the
impression that dentists were pretty
fond of artificial sweeteners is that is
that not the case I have no idea yeah so
I've always been under the impression
that from a dental person I mean it's
been years since I did in my dentistry
schooling that's a joke we should hit up
our our buddy Dave Maconie how we should
yeah but my understanding was that this
switch from like sugar gum to sugar-free
gum that was you know includes
non-nutritive sweeteners that they were
stoked about that now certainly diet
sodas are quite acidic I believe and
maybe that would be bad for tooth enamel
literally my my expertise here is coming
from stuff I've heard on commercials on
television about toothpastes so the only
reason I bring it up is because I was
under the impression that artificial
sweeteners were viewed as pretty benign
when it comes to dental stuff but we'll
check with Dave and when we'll check
back in but I did want to talk about
some of the common concerns people have
with artificial sweeteners so I'm gonna
say artificial sweetener but really what
we're talking about is a non-nutritive
sweeteners or extremely extremely
low-calorie sweeteners you know because
technically things like stevia wouldn't
necessarily be can be considered
artificial but
basically we're talking about sweeteners
that are so extremely sweet that they
are able to provide the sweetening
effect of sugar while providing
essentially no calories basically so few
calories you just wouldn't even bother
to to calculate them when it comes to
common concerns with with non-nutritive
or artificial sweeteners people always
bring up stuff about cancer risk they
talk about it's the potential effects on
appetite glycemic control or blood sugar
control and then also more recently the
gut microbiome has become a big topic so
there was a recent study about stevia
extract looking at glucose responses and
energy intake so it was a three arm
crossover trial it is kind of
interesting people lean on stevia when
they're like the artificial stuff scares
me but I stevia is natural so I'm good
in reality stevia we really don't have a
lot of research on it compared to some
of the other sweeteners like I feel
better about aspartame than stevia
theoretically just because there's been
like a billion aspirin - say aspartame
yeah there's been like a billion
aspartame studies I feel like and I
could be completely wrong here so dear
listener don't put any stock in this
whatsoever
but I feel like I saw a review a while
back looking at the evidence related to
artificial sweetener consumption and
cancer and they were like yeah we have a
bunch of studies on aspartame it seems
fine we have a few on sucralose so far
it seems fine
a sulfate potassium don't have that much
on it but from what we have it seems
fine only have one study on CV on stevia
and it seems like it causes stomach
cancer I didn't see that one I could be
completely making that up I think I read
that back in like 2014-2015 and and in
the authors of the review said like hey
don't put a ton of stock in this this
was a reasonably small study we don't
have much confidence in these results
but it it's pretty much saying exactly
what you were like all of the rest there
was there was a reasonable amount of
and stevia they were like we don't have
much in what we have doesn't look great
but uh not gonna throw out any super
strong conclusions yet yeah I did I find
it very ironic that people just lean on
stevia because of that like appeal the
nature fallacy of like it's got to be
the best one and in reality like I'm
much more interested in the ones that we
have a ton of data on I mean the other
thing about stevia is it's [ __ ]
disgusting that's a good scientific
argument I mean like sucralose tastes
good it's not as good as sugar but I I
legitimately think it's quite tasty
sucralose is good aspartame isn't great
it has like kind of a chemically
aftertaste I would say be you can hide
it in it in a dish pretty well it's it's
usable stevia is disgusting it's like I
would say its flavor profile is is one
part sweet to like four parts bitter
yeah it's just not good yeah I trust
people less when they tell me they use
stevia because that that reveals to me a
capacity for self-deception that makes
me doubt everything that comes out of
their mouth that's an interesting
outlook on life now that's kind of
sarcastic don't send me hate mail but
only kind of there is a kernel of truth
I'm not gonna lie it's TV is so nasty
this is a funny story a lot of people
don't know I forget which artificial
sweetener it is but it's one of the big
ones but the story behind its discovery
was there was like a chemistry student
like a grad student who's just like
working all hours day and night and you
know their their advisor was leaving for
the day and was like hey I'm heading out
make sure you test those samples though
for whatever kind of chemical testing
they were doing and it was either the
advisor or the student English was was
their second language and one of them
had like an accent and so the way the
grad student registered the instruction
was make sure you test was taste yeah
they said make sure you taste those
samples and this as the story goes the
next day the adviser goes in
comes in and student goes yeah I tasted
the sample they were really sweet like
super sweet and he was like holy [ __ ]
you ate that like I don't know if you
can I'm 85 percent sure that was
saccharine I I think that might be the
case yeah but anyway let's get back to
stevia what they did was a crossover
study here and they did three preloads
so the general idea here with with 30
participants --is they brought him into
the lab three different times and they
gave them a preload so there was a
standardized breakfast and then a
preload where they consumed either water
a 60 grams sugar dose or a stevia dose
of equivalent sweetness approximately
and then after a period of waiting time
they had an ad libitum pizza lunch
basically meaning there's a bunch of
pizza out eat as much as you want and
then they also had them do they looked
at some blood blood glucose levels after
the meal and they had them fill out a
food log throughout the rest of that day
to try to get an idea of well maybe
instead of affecting what they ate
during the ad libitum meal in the lab
maybe they compensated later in the day
or something like that so that's like
the basic idea of the key things they
were looking at here and what they found
was for the the different preloads
whether it was water sugar or stevia
there was not a statistically
significant effect on how much pizza was
eaten at the subsequent meal in the lab
nor was there a significant effect on
the calories consumed over the course of
that entire day what they found was that
the this basically the subjective scores
for hunger and desire to eat were lower
after the stevia preload compared to the
water preload when it came to the
glucose levels after the meal they found
obviously they adjusted for the fact
that one group had a huge dose of sugar
right before but after accounting for
that they basically found that the the
post meal or the postprandial glucose
levels were not significantly different
between between those interventions so
that the conclusions they drew here with
that stevia lowered appetite sensation
and did not for
increased food intake or blood glucose
levels after the meal because that's one
of the things a lot of people worry
about with these with artificial
sweeteners a lot of people worry if I
get this sense of immense sweetness in
the absence of calories is that gonna
basically make me hungry or make my body
seek out these calories that are
apparently missing you know what I mean
and the the research today would not
seem to indicate that that as a thing
that happens
there was another recent study shifting
gears from stevia to sucralose now this
one looked at those glycemic responses
as well but it also looked at the gut
microbiome and so Gregg as always you
let the listeners down you promised we
wouldn't talk about feces but here we
are
or did I promise we want it somebody
promised we want it but we're Thomas
feces I promised we would yeah okay yeah
you're right then so we're talking feces
if we've interrupted your romantic
evening I do apologize but what we've
got here we're looking at sucralose also
known as Splenda seeing how it would
affect these glycemic responses now with
this one it was not like an acute thing
what they did was they checked out their
they did an initial oral glucose
tolerance test then they gave them a
high dose of sucralose for a seven day
period and then they brought them back
and they redid the oral glucose
tolerance test to look at that glycemic
control those variables they also did a
fecal sample before and after that
seven-day supplementation period and it
was a big dose of sucralose it was
equivalent to about 20 diet sodas per
day and this was a placebo controlled
trial and so what they found basically
was compared to placebo those seven days
of sucralose consumption did not seem to
affect the glycemic control variables
that they looked at and also did not
have a meaningful effect on the gut
microbiome so some general points I want
to make about artificial sweeteners you
know there have been several studies
looking at a variety of sweeteners and
their their relationship to cancer risk
a few of them have reported like a few
select studies
a variety of different sweeteners have
reported an increased risk of various
cancers much of that obviously in rodent
studies but but most of these studies
have found no relationship and the few
III haven't looked into the the kind of
aftermath of that stevia study that you
mentioned so I just did because I don't
want to be an alarmist okay
it was it was a dose-response study in
vitro looking to see if if stevia
extract could cause a mutagenic effects
like whether it could cause gene
mutations which could potentially lead
to cancer and it can but at a dosage or
a concentration that would be similar to
approximately 4000 times the like
recommended upper intake level that
would be a high intake yeah so and these
are cells in a dish right vitro right so
to to to nuance what I said previously
all of the human research on stevia
right now still very limited it doesn't
seem to cause cancer but don't consume
4,000 times as much of it as is
recommended because maybe then it could
a very reasonable recommendation to stay
under that 4,000 times limit but but
with these various sweeteners you know
there are some select studies here and
there that do you know you'll see the
big headline that says Oh apparently
does give you cancer they're typically
using models that aren't easy to
extrapolate to what a real human being
would do in some there was an aspartame
paper I think it was the aspartame paper
where there was an increase in some type
of cancer in you know basically in
rodents that were bred to get cancer and
it was a type of cancer for which
there's no human equivalent like there's
just absolutely nothing in our
physiology that would be considered a
similar cancer for aspartame
specifically as well I so this isn't an
area of the literature I particularly
care that much about but my
understanding was that essentially like
the
the primary enzyme or enzymatic pathway
that one would use to metabolize
aspartame either doesn't exist in
rodents or is dramatically less active
and therefore you know you with a lot of
things you can kind of assume that at
least to some degree what we find in
humans will will generalize maybe
strongly maybe maybe weakly to humans
like that's that's why a lot of like
exploratory drug studies use rodents as
subjects but my understanding was that
like due to those metabolic differences
linked specifically to aspartame
metabolism you really shouldn't at all
attempt to generalize aspartame studies
from rodents to humans yeah I mean there
there are many cases in which you'll see
like like I said those little one or two
studies here there and then the
scientific community usually goes like
come on like you knew that that wasn't
the right animal model or you know that
that cancer is not relevant to human
health or you know that that dose is
absurd
there's usually for all the studies
where we do find that there's usually
some degree of backlash where the the
scientific community basically says like
come on like that that headlines crazy
and so like there have been a number of
good reviews and meta-analyses
indicating that for basically for all
the sweeteners that are out there on the
market currently we feel pretty
confident about their safety in general
particularly as it as it pertains to
cancer like we've mentioned there are
some some sweeteners with a lot more
evidence than others which is something
useful to keep in mind but I do think a
lot of people that are a bit
distrusting of large bodies whether
they're governments or international
health organizations they're like you
guys don't have the guts to actually ban
something and if there's bad evidence
you'll just you'll just kind of scoff at
it and ignore it but there is precedent
like that the FDA has banned a
non-nutritive sweeteners before and so
there was one called cyclamate that I
think in the US they banned it and I
believe in 1969 after some evidence that
it increased bladder cancer
in rats now the European Union did not
ban it and has not banned it and so I I
didn't do a deep dive into the cyclamate
literature but it looks like most of the
scientific community believes that it
probably shouldn't be banned and that
they're not super concerned about it
which is why there are governments all
over the world that have been like we we
saw that study we're not super worried
about it and they they neglected to ban
it and I don't even really know how
often it's used in other countries like
but but in any case the point is like
there is precedent where the US
government the FDA would look at the
research and say we feel uncomfortable
about that let's go ahead and ban it so
I think that does at least a little bit
to counteract that kind of notion like
ah that the big food companies are too
powerful the government would never
stand up to them like it's been done the
fact that like all these other countries
like if they are using it to a
meaningful amount in their food supply
that alone should probably be pretty
telling like if if we haven't identified
any population level issues with it in
those countries that use it like
probably not that big a deal if you look
at you know 30 governments and 29 of
them didn't think there was sufficient
cause to ban it like I don't want anyone
in the European Union right now to be
hearing this and going like oh my god
what but I don't know if anybody's using
it but in any case there there have been
instances where people say like I don't
like this evidence we're gonna go ahead
and ban it so like the stuff that is on
the market the sweeteners that are out
there and not banned like you can feel
pretty good that that national and
international organizations have
bothered to look through the evidence
and make an informed decision about
whether or not it should be on the
market and permissible to sell as a food
additive now there have been getting
away from cancer there there have been
some researchers and and non researchers
who suggest that maybe fake sweeteners
may mess up our metabolism or mess up
our gut microbiome and that these things
will affect our blood sugar control or
maybe affect our appetite cause
us to overeat there have been some
cross-sectional studies that say like oh
look at that people who have artificial
sweeteners tend to have higher BMI looks
like there's causation there
generally speaking the real and that's a
ridiculous premise because obviously
you're thinking well who's consuming a
ton of these products right a man I
can't put my finger on who but someone
famously said I've never seen a skinny
person drinking diet coke wasn't that
wasn't that Trump it was excellent yes I
mean he's been way ahead of the curve on
a lot of this health research he called
out that reverse causation which
basically what we're getting at like a
cross-sectional study like that probably
a lot of people who have weight loss as
a goal say I better you know switch over
to some of these diet sodas and and you
know reduce sugar products that have
artificial sweeteners in them so a lot
of the actual longitudinal controlled
evidence shows us that those concerns
about you know messing up appetite
regulation or glycemic control they we
really don't see notable issues in the
most well controlled studies that
actually assess it and you know if we're
talking about a good randomized
longitudinal trial versus a
cross-sectional study
I'm taking that randomized trial 11
times out of 10 you know so those
concerns while while I certainly
understand the concerns at the surface
level where you're thinking like oh well
if my body thinks there's sugar but
there's no calories maybe that's gonna
cause me to overeat that doesn't appear
to be justified by the research and
there is a great deal of research
looking at that when it comes to the
microbiome stuff
I mean honestly we we did a great
interview with Gabrielle food ro or food
in Sderot but but she she was talking to
us and kind of confirmed my what I
suspected which is people who make
really bold claims about what what a
good or a bad change in microbiome looks
like or a lot of times getting a little
bit ahead of the science you know like
we can do some of these interventions
like and we say okay well there's a
little change there in the general
makeup of the gut microbiome but it's
still really difficult for us in many
circumstances to say whether or not that
change was good or bad
and whether or not it was good or bad
enough to make a functional difference
in anything we care about so there are
some studies looking at changes in gut
microbiome and you know there there is
some evidence that there are changes for
a few of them I had a note about that
where'd it go yeah yeah so it might be
altered by some degree to some degree by
saccharin sucralose and stevia much of
that research showing alterations in the
gut microbiome a lot of that has been
done in animal models so for example the
human stuff was sucralose looks pretty
good in terms of gut microbiome at least
the most recent studies I've seen but in
any case just because there's a change
in the gut microbiome that that doesn't
immediately mean like oh crap there's a
huge problem here and so I think
sometimes people get a little bit too
overzealous about interpreting that and
assuming that it's going to cause all
sorts of problems so for now based on
the evidence we have I think the
evidence related to most of the common
artificial sweeteners looks pretty
pretty damn good I mean I consume
artificial sweeteners within reasonable
doses never think twice about it they
don't seem to induce any kind of really
meaningful negative effects when we look
at even fairly large samples in the
controlled trials that have been done
the one caveat there is something we've
alluded to you can't just say
non-nutritive sweeteners and assume that
all of them have all the same effects
right so it is possible that that some
do have a more notable effect on the gut
microbiome than others or and that's
just for example so you got to fight
that temptation to say what's true for
one non-nutritive sweeteners is true for
all of them because these are very very
diverse compounds and molecules the
thing they have in common is that
they're really damn sweet and that's
about where the similarities end
completely different compounds alright I
too have one final segment here well I'm
also going to play us out talk about
food a little bit but in terms of of
research based stuff so
there was an article published on a
personal blog back in November that I
just recently became aware of because I
I think it was updated February 5th and
and got picked up by some bigger sites
and was shared around a little bit more
than so I recently just became aware of
this but the title of the article is
matthew walker's why we sleep is riddled
with scientific and factual errors the
author is Alexei Guzzi and it was
published on his personal site and so if
you didn't know Matthew Walker is
probably probably the most well known
sleep researcher in the world
he wrote a popular book called why we
sleep which is what this article is
criticizing at least debunking I think
would be a more accurate description or
at least like debunking a lot of the
claims in it but yeah Matthew Walker
wrote a popular book it was a
best-seller he got a TED talk his TED
talk is one of the more popular TED
talks that has occurred I think the
title was like why sleep is your
superpower so you know very TED esque
title I could I mean this was big like
I'm pretty sure I heard Thom Yorke from
Radiohead talking about this in an
interview oh geez like I mean that this
thing made ripples it was a big book
yeah yeah let's see so on the back of
all of that success he parlayed a career
at Stanford into a job at Google I think
he may still work at Stanford but anyway
Matthew Walker huge huge deal in the
sleep world he's published a lot like
he's published and you know virtually
every high-impact ER a know where one
would publish sleep research and has
also you know parlayed that into
becoming the closest thing to a sleep
public intellectual that there could be
so anyway he wrote this book why we
sleep and the the author of this article
Alexei koozie went through just looked
at the first
chapter picked out a lot of unambiguous
concrete statements and just showed them
to be complete lies there's really no
other way to express it so I don't want
to you know basically go point by point
through this entire article but one of
the one like so one of the statements
made in the book on page three in
Chapter one is routinely sleeping less
than six or seven hours a night
diminishes your immune system more than
doubling your risk of cancer okay so
that is a pretty strong unambiguous
claim Matthew Walker doesn't give a
citation for that claim in his book so
the author of this article Alexey Guzzi
went through tried to see what is the
best evidence that is out there that
could possibly relate to that claim he
found a systematic review from 2018
looking at like all of the observational
research that existed looking at the
association between sleep duration and
cancer and so again the exact claim was
sleeping less than six or seven hours
per night demolishes your immune system
more than doubles your cancer risk okay
so take a guess what the actual odds
ratio was comparing six hours of sleep
versus eight hours of sleep in that
systematic review and meta-analysis I'll
let you think about that for a second
again Matthew Walker's claim is a
two-fold increase so an odds ratio of
two would correspond to that so just
think for a second what do you think the
actual odds ratio is I'm gonna guess
1.95 rounded up to two see that's not it
that's not a terrible guess but it's
actually 1.01 which for those keeping
score at home is not a two-fold increase
in cancer risk but is in fact a 1%
increase in cancer approximately double
sure yeah so anyway that was that was
the worst there was another one where he
talked about
sleeping five hours per night doubles
all calls mortality risk again the the
author of this article pulled up a
recent systematic review looking at that
and found that basically the the nadir
of the all cause mortality sleep
duration curve was about seven hours per
night and that five hours per night and
eight hours per night were actually
associated with virtually identical all
calls mortality which you know is
considerably different than the claim
that you double all cause mortality
sleeping less than seven to eight hours
per night anyway so there are a lot of
examples I'm not gonna ruin the article
for you go read it it's it may be the
most brutal intellectual takedown I've
ever witnessed in all of my days and to
be clear he didn't go through the entire
book nor did he cherry-pick the most
extreme claims everything he pulled out
in this article is just from the first
chapter of that book which is [ __ ]
brutal but anyway one of the things
brought up in that article which you
know to bring it home and make it
relevant for you guys is one of the
studies he cites one of seemingly few
claims that actually did have a citation
along with it was he was talking about
the risk of injury in athletes based on
how much they slept per night so the
study was chronic lack of sleep is
associated with increased sports
injuries and adolescent athletes so the
basically claiming that sleeping less
increases your injury rate and the
figure in the book shows a nice linear
decrease in injury rate as sleep
duration increases so at six hours per
night looks like injury rate was about
seventy five percent seven hours per
night about sixty percent at eight hours
per night about thirty five percent and
a little under twenty percent at nine
hours per night it looks nice nice
smooth linear decrease in injury rates
of the ass
elites in this sample as sleep duration
increased knoefel trend very easy to
explain correct so the issue is in that
actual study there was a five hour per
night cohort as well which did have a
higher injury rate than the like eight
and nine hour groups but it was like it
was also like sixty sixty five percent
so like slightly lower injury rates at
five hours versus six hours and you know
it wasn't a huge difference the overall
trend was still there where athletes
that slept more were less likely to
sustain an injury but it's it's really
not a good look when you're trying to
make a case and the totality of the data
in a study still supports the broad
argument you're trying to make but then
you just disregard one of the groups
because it doesn't make the trendline is
pretty so yeah it's just clipped it's
right Mary which I mean that's that's
arguably scientific malpractice like
it's it's not a good look but anyway so
that is that's what made me want to talk
about this on the podcast because we
have had a long-running injury series on
the site of which realistically kind of
should have all been published within a
month but I've been busy my co-author on
that Andrew Patton he's been busy it's
it honestly has fallen more on me than
him the delays but the final injury part
of that series is going to be up I think
within the next month or so it's it's
written just need to get it edited and
formatted so since that's coming up I
was like oh injuries this is interesting
so I wanted to see you know so Matthew
Walker just cites this one study in the
book and misrepresents it I wanted to
see like hey you know what does the
injury have to say about sleep duration
sleep disturbances and whether that
increases or affects your your injury
risk and so that wasn't something that
Andrew and I
that in our study so you know nice
little additional injury content to add
and so I found three fairly recent
systematic reviews and meta-analyses
looking at whether sleep effects injury
risk so the first one is titled sleep
problems and work injuries : a
systematic review and meta-analysis and
so I I feel like for all of these like
just one sentence from the abstract
explains them pretty well so for the
first 1:27 observational studies in of
almost two hundred and seventy thousand
participants so shit-ton of participants
twenty seven observational studies that
provided 54 relative risk estimates were
included the findings of the
meta-analysis suggested that workers
with sleep problems had a one point six
two times higher risk of being injured
than workers without sleep problems so
relative risk one point six two
relatively tight ninety five percent
confidence interval so between one point
four three and one point eight four so
roughly a sixty percent increase in
injury risk from having sleep problems
so that's not just you know short sleep
duration that's really kind of any sort
of sleep problem but 60 percent injury
risk with a relatively tight confidence
interval that's that's noteworthy I
would say second one chronic lack of
sleep is associated with increased
sports injury in adolescence this is a
systematic review and meta-analysis so
from this one of the nine hundred and
seven identified articles seven met
inclusion criteria in our random effects
model adolescents who chronically slept
poorly were more likely to be injured
than those who slept well odds ratio one
point five eight confidence interval
much bigger this time between one point
oh five and two point seven three so
because of that big confidence interval
that that's a much less precise measure
and it was barely significant so p-value
of 0.03 but the the actual like relative
increase in injury risk seemed to be
pretty similar so about a sixty percent
increase and then the third one sleep
problems in injury risk among juveniles
a systematic review and
analysis of observational studies a
total of 10 observational studies
involving about 73,000 participants were
identified meta-analysis finding
suggested the juveniles with sleep
problems had a 1.6 4 times higher risk
of injury than juveniles without sleep
problems and pretty tight confidence
interval there as well so about 1.4 for
to about 1.8 5 so none of these none of
these are looking at adult athletes or
you know even better yet would be adult
strength athletes or lifters so you know
work injuries and then two studies and
youth and adolescent so you know not
necessarily the best the best
populations for for us but I think it's
noteworthy that they all come to similar
similar estimates of the increased risk
so all three of them seemed like
basically sleeping poorly or not
sleeping enough increase your injury
risk by about 60% give or take and two
of those had a reasonably nice tight
confidence interval so that's a that's a
pretty non negligible increase in injury
risk just from sleeping poorly one of
the things that one of the things we've
talked about on the podcast before and
that I was recently while both of us
were recently bought involved in a
conversation about on Omar Aesop's
YouTube channel was kind of like what is
the nature of pain and injury and so if
they defined it in some of these studies
is like you know an injury is like are
you experiencing pain for a long time
one thing to note is that sleep like
poor sleep not sleeping enough can
increase the perception of pain so like
you know maybe there wasn't maybe it
didn't increase the risk of like
structural damage by 60% but you know
maybe it increased the risk of
structural damage by 40% and then the
other 20% is just an increase in pain
sensitivity because you're sleeping poor
leave it like that that's something that
is is very possible at least but it does
seem like here's the frustrating thing
there there seems to be
a whole lot of evidence in a lot of
different populations that's sleeping
less and sleeping poorly does increase
your risk of injury and Matthew Walker
could have pulled those meta-analyses
and been like hey we have a lot of
systemic evidence in different
populations with very large samples that
if you sleep less increases your injury
risk by like 60% like that that is a
claim that could be made that would have
a lot of evidence backing it up and
instead what he chose to do is like use
one single study another thing to note
about the study he used is the nine-hour
group with the really really low injury
risk like 18 percent injury risk that
was based on one injury out of six
subjects which like bro if you can sign
a [ __ ] meta-analysis that has two
hundred and sixty-eight thousand
participants and you go with one study
where one of your groups has six
subjects it's not a good look
anyway TLDR here is you want to reduce
your injury risk sleeping more certainly
doesn't hurt a lot of the things Matthew
Walker says about sleep yeah broad
message that haze sleep is good and you
should do it probably correct the
individual claims made in his book
especially kind of the bigger more I
guess inflammatory ones maybe don't put
a ton of stock in them and I really
recommend reading Alex Alexi goosies
article it's a like I said it it's
absolutely brutal
it really was yeah I didn't realize that
that was one out of six he I saw in a
Lexi's article he said one out of six I
thought he was just presenting the the
ratio I didn't realize he literally
meant there were six subjects in that
particular category you have a coach's
corner coming up as you get into that I
will look back at the article just to
verify but I'm 90% sure it was just six
subjects yeah so this Coaches Corner is
extremely brief and it does relate so
Greg mentioned we were on that round
on how do you say Omar's last name Esau
so we're on Omar Yusuf's
YouTube channel and great Greg and I
we're kind of hanging around you know we
didn't steal the spotlight it was a
really good conversation if you haven't
listened you should check it out
you're grinning over there did you get
your answer here's a direct quote as an
aside that nine hours of sleep column is
based on exactly one child being injured
out of six children who've reported
sleeping for nine hours oh my goodness
Wow okay well there you go my brain is
so forgiving that I just immediately
edited that to say like oh that's about
one in six no I need to really get a
more cynical brain don't I that's why
you and I compliment each other but
anyway we're in that Roundtable if you
haven't listened to it it's great a lot
of talking between Mike Israel and the
barbell medicine guys Jordan and Michael
ray over there we've had Michael on the
podcast to talk about pain a little bit
one of the things that came up in it
that I was wishing I would have kind of
interjected and gotten the discussion
going that way but there were so many
people already it was like you were
almost afraid to like introduce a new
tangent because you didn't want to you
want to be respectful of everybody's
time but one of the things that comes up
sometimes when it comes to injury risk
and training you know a lot of people
wonder how important is technique for
injury risk and I think at the very
basic level of course it's got to be
important to some extent right I mean
the way we are moving by definition
dictates what kind of forces are going
to be going across what kind of tissues
okay
so at the very basic level you'd say
well of course to some extent obviously
technique of movement is going to affect
injury risk sometimes you'll hear people
say no no it's it's all load management
like you can adapt to any kind of
movement technique as long as you manage
your load properly and so I'll hear that
sometimes just on you know on the
internet people arguing about stuff the
reason that that
take your line of thinking needs a
little bit of clarification in my
opinion is because I don't believe you
can actually separate those as truly
independent factors so you know
technique versus training load the
reason I say I don't think you can
separate them is because if you go from
good effective efficient technique that
is focusing most of the most of the load
most of the force toward your
contracting muscle rather than having it
overload a bunch of non contractile
tissues you know putting a bunch on the
bone joint ligament etc you know if you
have really good efficient technique
those contractile tissue the contractile
muscle is absorbing a huge you know
percentage of that force everything's
good all the other structures are happy
if you then transition to really awful
technique that is extremely inefficient
and shifting a lot of that burden for
lack of a better term in terms of the
forces shifting that toward non
contractile passive tissues in my
opinion that can turn a very manageable
training load into an unmanageable
training load because of the way that
you are diverting those forces to other
non muscle tissues if that makes sense
so when we talk about having a
manageable training load and managing it
appropriately I don't really believe you
can separate that from technique because
the technique is going to determine
exactly how much force is going on to
these these other tissues that could be
vulnerable to structural damage and and
so I you know that the main point is
what is a manageable training load with
great technique could become an
unmanageable training load with poor
technique and movement and so that's one
thing that I don't want people to lose
and I would hate for people to view that
as a binary thing of is it technique or
is it how much load or how much training
load is occurring there another thing
that came up in the discussion is when
and how you should go about
troubleshooting technique so I think a
common thing like Greg I'm sure most
people when they come to you for
training advice they've been training
awhile they have a
want technique and they have a deadlift
technique and it might not be
picture-perfect right and so that for
sure so the question is when someone
comes in and they're like well this is
how I've been dead lifting for five
years at what point do you say well
that's fine but I want to tweak it and I
think a lot of people you know a lot of
people do think like every lift has to
be picture-perfect like a textbook and
if it's not then we need to rebuild it
from scratch and I think that is
probably not a great way to go about
doing it if someone is like pretty close
to perfect but there's a little you know
there could be some improvement here and
there but they're lifting with a great
deal of efficiency they're very strong
there's no pain there's no like really
nasty dysfunctional movement going on in
many cases you can roll with it you know
they're pretty much adapted to that
technique for them however I don't want
people to misinterpret that and think
that you have to wait until there's pain
or dysfunction or an actual major
structural issue before you feel
comfortable intervening and saying why
don't we tried tweaking technique a
little bit you know so I again it's one
of those things that I think there's
been a lot of progress in the lifting
world of shifting the conversation and
saying like yeah you could have pretty
good technique that maybe isn't textbook
picture perfect you can probably adapt
to that and lift successfully with it
and that's a good thing but I would I
would fear that people who coach others
sometimes take that a little too far and
and fail to intervene when they could
really improve a lifters technique in a
way that's not only likely to minimize
their injury risk or allow them to train
with a greater overall training load in
a safe way but like if you can make it
more efficient lower injury risk but
also make it more efficient so they're
going to perform better I think
sometimes it is okay to intervene and
say like I know you're not in pain right
now but that's pretty rough and we can
probably make that a more efficient lift
that if nothing else is going to improve
your numbers and actually improve the
quality of our training yeah that makes
sense yeah I agree I mean so I think
tissues are incredibly adaptable
and often much more so than we expect /
give them credit for but at the same
time if you don't have to bet on that
maybe you shouldn't Ram so you know for
example if you look at if you look at a
lot of weight lifters in their catch
position for a snatch or clean you're
often going to see not always so it kind
of depends on kind of what country the
lifters from and how they're built but
especially with like Russian and Eastern
European lifters you'll often see a very
considerable amount of knee valgus and
like hip internal rotation like
functional valgus going on which like
you know they're fine they've been
they've been doing that for decades they
don't seem to be tearing their ACL or
MCL from doing so but you know in
weightlifting the low man wins and
that's how they can get as far under the
bar possible you know to catch a snatch
or clean and jerk that doesn't
necessarily mean that if you're seeing
relatively extreme functional valgus in
a recreational lifter when they do their
squats you maybe shouldn't say something
about it because even though those
tissues very well may adapt and they
very well may be fine
they also very well may be increasing
long-term risk and you don't necessarily
want to just bet that oh those tissues
will adapt and that'll take care of it
even though they're very well made and
like you said in a lot of cases and a
lot of cases changing what seems to be
oftentimes what seems to be bad
technique maybe from an injury
perspective is also bad technique from a
performance perspective so you know you
might be taking one step back to take
two steps forward from a performance
perspective as well and I definitely
think that if you can conceivably make a
performance based argument you would be
wise to do so just so you know
potentially nocebo your client yeah I
very much agree with everything you just
said yeah I fully agree and I do think
that's even a better way to frame it you
know like you said of course that the
tissues could adapt to that but if you
don't have to gamble on it you know
maybe don't but but the real benefit
there is even if it's a potentially
injurious Technic flaw that may never
manifest in a real noticeable injury
usually by cleaning that up you're gonna
make it a much stronger lift and you're
also like I said you're probably gonna
open it up to the to the point where you
can get away with a greater overall
training load without having to worry
about that potentially injurious
movement becoming injurious so I you
know I certainly don't want to frame it
in a way that any listeners would think
like oh crap if I don't have a picture
perfect squatter deadlift I'm just
counting down the days till I sustain an
injury but but I do fear light like you
said that example you got a brand new
lifter that you're coaching that is like
pretty pretty new to lifting and there
are just really noticeable pretty
blatant flaws in the movement that
you're like I don't really like how that
works I would hate for people to
over-interpret some of the stuff they
hear that's more relevant to really
advanced lifters and say well if there's
no you know as long as the bones not
sticking out of the skin you're supposed
to just go with it I guess you know I
don't want people to take it that far in
and certainly remember that what applies
to a really really advanced lifter who
has like slight back rounding on a
deadlift does not necessarily apply to
somebody who's just getting into lifting
and has like really really major
technique flaws with any particular
lifts like it's worth it early in a
career to take the time to like I said
not every lift has to be picture-perfect
but we'd like to at least get it within
a functional range that looks pretty
solid pretty efficient and pretty stable
all right Greg to play us out the to
play us out is basically becoming like
Greg's kitchen tips here so we got
another kitchen tip why don't you play
us
we're gonna be we might even go over
three hours for all the listeners who
have been upset that we're cutting them
at two and a half I mean this is this is
Bonus Time oh yeah let's do it so
looking back at the cooking tips I'd
given so far I was actually a little
shocked that I haven't talked about this
yet however if you've never heard of
sous-vide you've heard about it now and
you should look into it it is amazing
for food prep so what is sous-vide
essentially it's a French word that I
should know the translation of but I
don't it's a French term don't know the
translation but what it is functionally
is you you put your food generally it's
going to be meat in a bag you can use
vacuum seal bags but just a ziplock bags
work fine you submerge that in water and
then there's a heater slash circulator
element which is the piece of it you
need to buy plugs into the wall and what
it's going to do is it's going to heat
the water up to your desired temperature
and it's going to circulate it to make
sure that everything within your cooking
vessel stays the same temperature and so
the reason why that is good is that it
basically makes sure that you can have
perfect temperature control of whatever
you're cooking and it helps things stay
really really moist and juicy if
especially if it's something that has a
tendency to become dry as you cook it
like in the oven or on the stove in both
of those circumstances you're going to
have some degree of water loss from the
meat as it cooks the fibers will
contract force liquid out but you're
also going to have some degree of water
loss due to evaporation and when
everything's in a sous-vide bag nothing
is evaporating so it helps lock in the
juices a lot better and so some
potential applications for it one is you
know let's say you've baked a lot of
chicken breasts in your life you're like
yeah you know the macros are good it's
not particularly tasty it can be a
little dry at times
but you know hey you got to do what you
got to do you can absolutely make
beautiful delicious baked chicken
breasts I've talked about brining I
think on the podcast before certainly on
my Instagram brining can go a long way
to improving the juiciness and texture
of white meat chicken but to make it
even easier you can sous-vide those
chicken breasts and they're going to
come out incredibly so I think the
minimum temperature you want to get
chicken up to is like 165 if you're and
so another advantage of sous-vide I'll
note is that you can sometimes get away
with cooking things at a slightly lower
temperature than you otherwise would
because the way pasteurization works is
as temperature gets higher and higher
and higher it kills bacteria at an
increasingly high rate and so
essentially for most things if they get
up above 185 190 if they're at that
temperature for like three seconds all
of the bacteria are dead but you could
have otherwise like brought them up to
say 150 or 155 for like an hour and that
would also do a similarly good job of
killing all of the bacteria and so like
one advantage is for something like
chicken that you may be used to getting
up to 185 190 you can feel a little
safer cooking it at a slightly lower
temperature which is going to help
preserve more juices leaving it there
for an hour - still going to do a good
job killing all the bacteria and then
when it comes out it's going to be
perfectly cooked if you want to get the
flavor from the my yard reaction at that
point you can just Pat it dry sear it
you know only have to sear it super hot
for maybe a minute or two you get you
know a nice sear on it but you don't
have to worry about spending a lot of
time you know trying to cook it in a pan
to get that nice sear and also cooked
all the way through so generally you
wind up with a lot juicier meat really
really great texture it's a very time
efficient way to cook it's set it and
forget it much the same way a crock-pot
or a slow cooker would be so you know
you stick stuff in the bag you zip it up
you walk away you come back
it's cooked it's cooked perfectly it's
absolutely beautiful you have way more
control over it than you do a crock pot
or slow cooker and since everything's
locked in the bag you're also losing
less so you you preserve all of the
liquid within the crock pot but not
necessarily within the meat like it can
still evaporate out of the meat and just
into the crock pot generally whereas
that doesn't happen with sous-vide it's
a lot more self-contained so it's quite
convenient as well so if you wanted to
go full bore with a sous-vide I know
that a lot of people recommend getting
vacuum bags and like a vacuum bag sealer
unit you don't have to do that if you
want to just stick your toes in the
sous-vide water you can just get a basic
a basic circulator and just use regular
ziplock bags something that works really
really well is what's called the water
displacement method essentially you just
put your meat down in the bag we try to
squeeze as much of the air out as you
can you don't have to be super
particular about it and just leave the
top cracked a little bit and then
submerge the bag down in water but not
up to the point where the crack is and
then the pressure from the water will
force essentially all of the air out of
the bag and then you know when only the
tiny little slit is still above the
water go ahead and close it up you get a
seal you get you get air removal that's
essentially on par with what you'd get
from a vacuum bag sealer but it's way
way cheaper in that you don't have to
buy anything except Ziploc bags so I'd
recommend that I haven't priced a
circulator in a while I've been on the
sous-vide game for a long time I got my
sous-vide circulator it's what I asked
for for Christmas in 2014 and so I want
to say I was planning on buying one
until Santa / my dad got it for me but I
think at the time they were maybe like a
hundred bucks give or take so fairly
affordable I think there's still
somewhere in that price range so you
know it's gonna be a significant
purchase but it's probably not gonna
break the bank for most people and
you'll get a lot of use out of it other
things you can do with sous-vide
is one if you really like very
collagenous meats and you need to break
that collagen down but you know you
don't have time to tend to smoker for 12
hours to make sure you know it goes low
and slow well enough or maybe you don't
particularly like braising in the oven
and like how much fat can get drawn out
of the meat or in the braising process
sous-vide can make just just beautiful
say beef ribs beef ribs are absolutely
delicious if they're cooked well if you
have time to break down all of that
collagen it's it's just so good but it's
also kind of difficult to do outside of
like braising or a slow cooker you can
cook say beef ribs sous-vide super super
easily just you know leave him in like
160-170 for 24 to 48 hours it's gonna
break down all of that collagen they're
gonna be fall apart tender super easy to
do way easier to do than pretty much any
other method I would say another benefit
of sous-vide is like I said I'm a big
fan of briny meat you can kind of get a
pseudo brine going on with sous-vide if
you seasoned the meat before you put it
in the bag so you know salted
appropriately then as it cooks some of
the the liquid will get drawn out of the
meat it's gonna combine with the salt
create a brine get absorbed back into
the meat so you don't just have salt on
the outside with me the outside of the
meat you're cooking it's going to
penetrate it fully so it gives you good
flavor through the entire cut of meat
you know that's not super crucial if
you're cooking something fairly thin but
if you're cooking say like a really
thick steak or even chicken breast
making sure that you have that seasoning
dispersed through the entire the entire
hunk of meat is pretty good and clutch
let's see one Oh another thing you can
do is sous-vide which is actually pretty
neat is you can cook eggs perfectly and
so for example if you really like
hard-boiled eggs but you have a tendency
to accidentally overcook them so the
yolk starts turning green and kind of
icky
I don't remember the exact settings you
can google it it's easy enough but you
can set your your circulator at the
perfect temperature that you can just
walk away 30 minutes you come back and
because the temperature control is so
precise you will have absolutely perfect
flawless hard-boiled eggs if you like
soft-boiled eggs and you like the yolk
to be at a very particular type of
consistency maybe you won't fully set
whites and completely runny yolks maybe
you kind of want like a custard a yolk
and doing it in a pot on the stove you
know the difference between having it in
water for five minutes and five minutes
and thirty seconds is enough to ruin the
egg from your perspective because you
don't get the yolk texture you want
never a problem with sous-vide you can
set it at an exact temperature to get
the exact yolk consistency you want set
it and forget it
perfect every time one one problem that
some people will have when they first
play around with sous-vide is you can
set it and forget it to a point and it's
a fairly forgiving cooking technique but
you can absolutely leave things cooking
for too long so for example if you're
trying to make chicken breasts and you
set the water at a hundred and
sixty-five degrees and you walk away for
an hour you're gonna come back it's
gonna be good chicken breast if you set
it for two hours come back it's gonna be
good chicken breast three hours yeah
probably still be fine if you start
cooking it say at the beginning of the
day you leave for work come back eight
hours later it will essentially just
turn the chicken breast to mush so you
can you can overcook things just because
you're leaving something heated for so
long so much of the proteins gonna break
down and in like I said it's going is
it's it's gonna stop having a nice
Pleasant bite as meat should and just
kind of turn mushy and gross but it is
it is still pretty forgiving but don't
just assume that hey I can you know put
something in tonight and tomorrow
morning it's gonna be great for some
things that's the case I give it
something with a fair amount of
connective tissue like ribs you know a -
up to 48 hours of cooking can be
perfectly awesome
whereas like if you want to cook steak
but you you know you still want a nice
bite to it you want to necessarily want
to do that oh that's the other like
super clutch thing about sous-vide if
you want to impress people and you want
to make like a perfect rare steak that's
heated all the way through but you know
not like there's not too much of a gray
ring around the outside or medium-rare
or whatever people like you can do that
so easy with sous-vide so you know if
you like your steak at a hundred and
twenty eight degrees what you can do is
just set the temperature at 125 drop the
steaks in come back hour and a half two
hours later it's gonna be 125 the whole
way through no part of the steak is
gonna be more than 125 no parts gonna be
less all you gotta do is Pat it dry get
a cast-iron pan as hot as it can
possibly get sear for like 30 seconds
aside get a nice crust on it that'll
bring the internal temp up that extra
like 2 3 degrees to get it up to the 128
you want and it's gonna be perfect every
time
super repeatable so anyway it's it's a
fairly flexible kitchen gadget it's not
super cheap but you will be able to get
a lot of use out of it and like I said
for I mean for people who are just into
cooking good food there's a lot of cool
[ __ ] you can do with it
oh another one I'm just pulling stuff
out of my ass right now another really
cool thing you can do with sous vide
going back to eggs is if you're someone
who's concerned about Salmonella from
like cookie dough but you like cookie
dough if you want to make pasteurized
cookie dough at home you can do it with
sous-vide because there is a very
particular temperature range where you
can get the eggs up too which is going
to pasteurize them without actually
cooking anything like it's not gonna set
the white it's not gonna start cooking
the yolk and so you can pasteurize your
eggs using sous-vide I think like a
hundred and I think it's like a hundred
and thirty four degrees Fahrenheit is
the sweet spot by the way every
temperature I've given up to this point
is Fahrenheit if people are listening to
this thinking Celsius and like oh [ __ ]
he's way over cooking a steak it's all
Fahrenheit
yeah I think like 134 Fahrenheit I think
is the magic range get the eggs there
for like 20-30 minutes give or take it
should pasteurize them and then you can
make cookie dough with eggs that behave
as if they're raw eggs but there's no
bacteria it's great same the same thing
with the flour you're not gonna
sous-vide that you're just gonna pop it
in the oven at like 350 for 20-30
minutes that'll heat it up enough to
pasteurize the flour yeah you can use
sous-vide to make beautiful pasteurized
eggs that will behave very very
similarly to raw eggs but be safe to eat
raw so yeah very very versatile like I
said the biggest benefit for people who
are into fitness is very lean typically
not super flavorful cuts of meat you can
cook them perfectly so that they're
still super juicy not overcooked not dry
and stringy very very useful kitchen
tool that I would strongly recommend to
you know anyone who who maybe wants to
spice up their food prep a little bit
yeah so there you have it if you want to
impress your Valentine's Day date and
give them just the perfect meal to
celebrate the occasion hurry up because
you have a lot of work to do in the next
day if you're listening to this the
moment it comes out all right well that
does it for this episode as always thank
you for listening and we'll have another
one in two weeks thanks for listening to
the stronger by science podcast now Greg
and I are not experts in medicine or
health or really anything else for that
matter so before you make any changes to
your diet and exercise habits make sure
you check with a doctor or another
healthcare professional if you enjoyed
this podcast and you'd like to support
it visit stronger by science com2 check
out the products and services that we
offer thanks for listening and we'll see
you next time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you